MORNING OR GOOD AFTERNOON I
SHOULD SAY IN RESPONSE TO THE
COVERT NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND HERE
TONIGHT SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THESE ORDERS THE
SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
EGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE ARE
HOLDING OUR ACT THE COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL-
AND WITH NO MEMBERS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. IN THE
SENATE CHAMBER WITH ME WE HAVE
SENATOR THOMAS J. AMBURG WE
EXPECT TO BE JOINED BY SENATORS
BEN ALLEN AND ANDREA SPLURGES.
WE ALSO HAVE REPRESENTATIVES
FROM A WIDE RANGE OF BACKGROUNDS
AND EXPERTISE WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. FOR OUR
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE
YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS
WILL GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING
ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. I ASK%
THAT EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED THAT USE THE RAISE
YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOU RECOGNIZE
TO SPEAK A POP UP WINDOW WILL
APPEAR ASKING IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO ON MUTE PLEASE SELECT ON YOU
BEFORE YOU BEGINNINGS. BEGIN
SPEAKING. R. I. T. PERSONNEL PUT
YOU BACK ON YOU WHEN YOU ARE
DONE. ONCE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK
PLEASE MAKE SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN
ON THE SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME
AND THAT YOU'RE READY TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
HEARING ROOM TO THE EXTENT THAT
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW. AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT. DIVERTISSEMENT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN
AND I WILL ALSO ANNOUNCE IT NOW
. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS
EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE.
SIX THREE SIX FOUR AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS SEVEN SIX NINE.
SEVEN ONE EIGHT EIGHT. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCE SYSTEM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. FOR
TODAY'S HEARING WE'LL BE HEARING
ALL OF THE PANELS OF WITNESSES
ON THE AGENDA PRIOR TO TAKING
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT OR QUESTIONS
FROM OUR MEMBERS. ONCE WE HAVE
HEARD ALL THE WITNESSES WILL
HAVE A PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD FOR
THOSE WHO WISH TO COMMENT ON THE
TOPIC OF TODAY'S AGENDA. PLEASE
NOTE IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. YOU MUST MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING HEARING
ON PRIOR TO GIVING TESTIMONY
OVER THE PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT
THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU AND WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I
WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHOSE DISRUPTIVE
MAYBE REMOVE THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS NEEDED. SO THAT WILL
BEGIN OUR INFORMATIONAL
OVERSIGHT HEARING THANK YOU ALL
FOR JOINING THE SENATE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON CYBER SECURITY AND
IDENTITY THEFT. PREVENTION
SECOND INFORMATIONAL HEARING IN
TODAY'S HEARING WILL DISCUSS
ISSUES IDENTITY THEFT AND FRAUD.
THEIR IMPACTS ON CONSUMERS
PREVENTION AND RESPONSE
RESOURCES AVAILABLE BOTH IN THE
PRIVATE AND PUBLIC SECTORS. AND
MOSTLY WE'RE GONNA BE LOOKING TO
TRY TO DRILL DOWN ON WHAT THE
SOLUTIONS ARE TO THE VEXING AND
GROWING PROBLEM OF IDENTITY
THEFT. ANY INDUSTRY AND ACADEMIC
EXPERTS ON IT IN EIGHTY FIVE FOR
PORT THAT IS NOT FRUITFUL TO ASK
IF YOU'RE IDENTIFYING
INFORMATION WILL BE STOLEN BUT
RATHER WHEN. IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE ALONE THE FEDERAL TRADE
COMMISSION RECEIVED NEARLY TWO
POINT EIGHT MILLION IDENTITY
THEFT INCIDENT REPORTS. WHICH
WAS UP FROM THE TWO POINT ONE
MILLION RECEIVED THE YEAR PRIOR
. OF THESE ATTACKS IMPOSTER
SCAMS ARE THE MOST COMMON WITH
ONLINE SHOPPING MAKING UP THE
SECOND MOST COMMON FORM OF
IDENTITY THEFT. WHICH MAKES
SENSE WITH THE INCREASING USE OF
ONLINE CONSUMER MARKETS DURING
THE COPA NINETEEN PANDEMIC. AND
THESE ATTACKS DO NOT COME
WITHOUT A COST EVERYDAY
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES. IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE CONSUMERS
REPORTED LOSING MORE THAN FIVE
POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS TO
FRAUD. INDICATING AN INCREASE OF
MORE THAN 70% FROM TWENTY TWENTY
. IN FACT OVER A THIRD OF ALL
CONSUMERS WHO FILED A FRAUD
REPORT THE FTC. REPORTED LOSING
MONEY WHICH WAS UP FROM 23%
TWENTY NINETEEN. THE FOCUS OF AN
ANTI THEFT ATTACKED INDIVIDUAL
TAX INDIVIDUALS AND THEIR LOVED
ONES IS DIFFICULT TO CALCULATE.
BECAUSE ONCE A PERSON'S
IDENTIFYING INFORMATION STOLEN
IT POSES A LONG TERM THREATS TO
ONE'S ECONOMIC STANDING AND WHAT
WELL BEING. THIS PERSONAL
INFORMATION CAN BE USED TO APPLY
FOR GOVERNMENT DOCUMENTS
BENEFITS LINES OF CREDIT OR MORE
ANY POINT IN TIME. AS WE WELL
KNOW THE BROAD EDT FRAUD THAT WE
SAW ACROSS ALL FIFTY STATES
OCCURRED IN LARGE PART BECAUSE
OF THE READY AVAILABILITY OF
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBERS AND
OTHER IDENTIFYING INFORMATION ON
THE DARK WEB. I CAN TESTIFY
PERSONALLY FOR THEM FROM MY OWN
EXPERIENCES ABOUT BEING SOMEONE
WHO IS FAMILIAR WITH IDENTITY
THEFT. I'VE ACTUALLY HAD MY DATA
BREACH THREE SEPARATE OCCASIONS.
AS PARTY EQUIFAX BREACH- OF UC
IRVINE'S IN THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA'S BREACH TO THE SALLY
ON DATA BREACH. AND AS A
CUSTOMER OF T. MOBILE I'M NOW
AWARE THAT MY INFORMATION AND
INFORMATION I THREE YOUNG
CHILDREN IS ACTUALLY ON THE DARK
WEB IN WE PERIODICALLY GET
REPORTS ABOUT THAT. THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT I'LL HAVE TO DO
WITH THE REST OF MY LIFE MORE
UNFORTUNATELY SOMETHING THAT MY
CHILDREN WILL HAVE TO DEAL WITH
THE REST OF THEIR LIVES. AND I'M
INCREASINGLY CONVINCED THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT ALL OF US WILL
HAVE TO DEAL WITH AND SO IT'S A
TIME IT'S TIME THAT WE START
COMING UP WITH SOLUTIONS.
LUCKILY THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
EXPERTS IN THE PRIVATE PUBLIC
AND ACADEMIC SECTORS WHO WORK
HARD EACH DAY TO. BOTH CREATE
SOLUTIONS THESE PROBLEMS. AND
SPREAD AWARENESS ABOUT THE
RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO
CONSUMERS. TODAY WE'RE JOINED BY
FEW THESE EXPERTS. WHO WANT TO
DISCUSS HOW TO SUPPORT. AND
COORDINATE THE PROTECTION OF
CALIFORNIA'S IDENTITY. OUR FIRST
PANEL WILL PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW
OF THE TYPES OF IDENTITY THEFT
AND FRAUD OCCUR AS WELL SHARE
THE IMPACT IT HAS ON CONSUMERS.
WILL HAVE ERIC ALMONDS THE
SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT OF PUBLIC
AFFAIRS AND CONSUMER DATA
IDENTITY ASSOCIATION TO SPEAK
FIRST. AND HE WILL BE JOINED BY
EVA VELASQUEZ- THE PRESIDENT AND
CEO OF THE IDENTITY THEFT
RESOURCE CENTER. THAT PANEL THEM
EVOLVE OUR SECOND PANEL WHICH
WILL DISCUSS ANY THEFT
PREVENTION RESPONSE AND
ENFORCEMENT RESOURCES. AVAILABLE
IN THE PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
SECTORS. JOINING US ON THAT
PANEL WILL BE TO TREVINO AUSTIN
CALIFORNIA'S DEPUTY ATTORNEY
GENERAL. AND CHAIRMAN GRANT
MANAGING DIRECTOR OF TECHNOLOGY
BUSINESS STRATEGY AND VENABLE
LLP. AFTER THE CONCLUSION BOTH
PANELS I'LL OPEN UP THE
DISCUSSION AND QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS FROM OUR MEMBERS.
BEFORE WE OPEN IT UP TO THE
PUBLIC TO PUBLIC COMMENT AND
THEN ADJOURNED THE HEARING. THE
GOAL FOR TODAY'S HERE ABOUT
EMERGING IDENTITY THEFT AND
FRAUD DANGERS THAT WE ALL FACE
DAILY. WHAT RESOURCES ARE
AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE SECTORS TO COMBAT
IDENTITY THEFT AND HOW WE HERE
IN THE LEGISLATURE CONSISTENT
PROVIDING SOLUTIONS. I WANT TO
THANK THE PANELISTS FOR JOINING
US TODAY. AND I THAT WOULD OPEN
UP THIS OPPORTUNITY MY
COLLEAGUES TO SEE IF THEY HAVE
ANY OPENING REMARKS THEY LIKE TO
SHARE AT THIS TIME. CENTER
NUMBER. THANK YOU CENTERMAN
THANK YOU FOR CONVENING THE
COMMITTEE AND THANK YOU FOR
ADDRESSING THIS CRITICAL ISSUE
TOO I THINK ALL CALIFORNIANS-
JUST VERY BRIEFLY. IN
YESTERDAY'S PAPERS WE NOTE THAT
THERE'S BEEN A LEAK OF
CONFIDENTIAL DATA FROM THE STATE
BAR TWO. HUNDRED AND SIXTY
THOUSAND CONFIDENTIAL RECORDS
THAT WERE LEAKED THIS WASN'T.
BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT MOST
BECAUSE OF PACKING IT WAS SIMPLY
BECAUSE THE SEARCH ENGINE
SOMEHOW- FOUND ITS WAY INTO THE
CONFIDENTIAL RECORDS OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE BAR SO THE
QUESTION IS IN TERMS OF
PROTECTION. HOW ADEQUATELY
PROTECTED ARE WE ARE WE
PROTECTED NOT JUST THE PRIVATE
SECTOR BUT IN THE PUBLIC SECTOR
FOR WHICH WE HAVE RESPONSIBILITY
AND SO AS WE EXPLORE THIS TOPIC-
MISTER CHAIR I AM HOPEFUL THAT
THAT WE ALSO CAN IF NOT TODAY IN
IN FUTURE HEARINGS. WE CAN
EXPLORE THE ADEQUACY OF THE
PROTECTIONS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
AFFORDED- CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS
WITH RESPECT TO THEIR
CONFIDENTIAL RECORDS. OUT WITH
WITH WHICH WE'VE BEEN ENTRUSTED
TO KEEP CONFIDENTIAL THANK YOU
AGAIN MISTER CHAIR- CENTER ON
YOUR COMMENTS. JUST IMMENSELY
INTERESTED IN THIS ISSUE IS
GOING TO GET WORSE GIVEN THAT
CERTAIN INTERNATIONAL- EVENTS
AND I WAS ONE ALSO I WANT TO
THANK AND APPLAUD THE CHAIR FOR
TAKING ON A LEADERSHIP ROLE IN
THIS AREA- FOR GETTING THIS
SELECT COMMITTEE GOING. I
APPRECIATE YOUR LEADERSHIP YOUR
SENTIMENT. AND YOU TURN AROUND
AND THE CENTRE BORDERS IS
JOINING US YOU HAVE ANY OPENING
REMARKS YOU LIKE TO ADD OKAY
FANTASTIC THANKS FOR JOINING US
ON OUR BORDERS AND I WOULD JUST
SAY I JUST TOOK THE CALIFORNIA
BAR EXAM SO WELL I'M I'M GLAD
THAT MY INFORMATION I THINK WAS
NOT PART OF THAT WEEK BUT IT
DOES SPEAK TO THE PROBLEM HERE
THAT WE SEE ACROSS BOTH THE
PRIVATE AND PUBLIC SECTORS.
BEFORE YOU GO WITH OUR SPEAKERS
I WOULD LIKE TO INVITE THE
PUBLIC WAITING TO WANTING TO
PARTICIPATE TO CALL IN NOW
PLEASE DIAL AGAIN THIS TOLL FREE
NUMBER. 844-291-6364 AND WHEN
PROMPTED PLEASE USE THIS ACCESS
CODE SEVEN SIX NINE. SEVEN ONE
EIGHT EIGHT HOW'S YOUR FROM OUR
FIRST PRESENTER ERIC ALLMAN THE
SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT OF PUBLIC
AFFAIRS AND CONSUMER DATA.
IDENTITY ASSOCIATION. GOOD
AFTERNOON. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. I'M ERIC
ELEMENT WITH THE CONSUMER DATA
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION CTIA WE OUR
TRADE ASSOCIATION OF CONSUMER
REPORTING AGENCIES AS DEFINED
BY. FEDERAL AND STATE LAW. OUR
MEMBERS ARE HIGHLY REGULATED
COMPANIES THAT AMONG OTHER
THINGS. GATHER STORE AND USE
PROTECTED DATA TO HELP
BUSINESSES. GOVERNMENTS AND
NONPROFITS MANAGE RISK. I WANT
TO THANK YOU MR CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
ALLOWING ME AN OPPORTUNITY TO
APPEAR WITH YOU. TODAY TO
PROVIDE AS MUCH INFORMATION AS I
CAN TO HELP BETTER UNDERSTAND
HOW IDENTITY THEFT IS PREVENTED.
AND REMEDIATED. BY OUR MEMBERS.
I WANT TO CONVEY TO YOU SEVERAL
POINTS. CBI MEMBERS ARE
RESPONSIBLE STEWARDS OF THE DATA
THAT THEY MAINTAIN IN PART
BECAUSE OF THE IT'S THE LAW. IN
PART BECAUSE IT'S THE RIGHT
THING TO DO. CTIA MEMBERS PLAY A
CRITICAL ROLE. IN THE MANAGEMENT
AND IDENTIFICATION OF. THE
BANISHMENT THE IDENTIFICATION
AND AUTHENTICATION. TO MAKE A
SHORT AS POSSIBLE THE BUSINESSES
GOVERNMENTS AND NONPROFITS. ARE
DOING BUSINESS WITH THE RIGHT
PEOPLE. THERE ARE LAWS IN PLACE
AT THE FEDERAL AND STATE LEVEL
TO PROTECT CALIFORNIANS AND
NATIONWIDE- BUT THERE'S ONE BILL
IN PARTICULAR TWELVE SENATE BILL
TWELVE SIXTY TWO BY YOUR
COLLEAGUE SENATOR BRADFORD. THAT
CAN GO A LONG WAY TO PROTECTING
CALIFORNIANS WHERE THEY LIVE.
AND WHERE THEY WORK. IDENTITY
THEFT IS A PROBLEM. IT WAS A
PROBLEM BEFORE THE PANDEMIC AND
IT'S BEEN EXACERBATED BY THE
PANDEMIC THIS IS BEEN ESPECIALLY
TRUE AGAINST GOVERNMENT AGENCIES
IN THE APPLICATION OF GOVERNMENT
BENEFITS LIKE SNAP. UNEMPLOYMENT
COMPENSATION- AND OTHERS AND THE
PRIVATE SECTOR HASN'T BEEN
IMPACTED AS WELL. FOR EXAMPLE
SHARING HITCHCOCK RECENTLY TOLD
THE F. T. C. A CALIFORNIA
RESIDENT BUT HER PERSONAL
INFORMATION WAS STOLEN AND THAT
SOMEONE HAD SIGNED UP FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT COMP IN HER NAME
SHE HAD ONE DEPOSITS INTO HER
BANK ACCOUNT WITH SOMEONE ELSE'S
NAME ON IT. AND SHE WAS HIT WITH
A TEN NINETY NINE G. FROM THE
IRS FOR TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS. I RETURN TO A SEMINAL
COMMENT MADE A NUMBER OF YEARS
AGO AT A CONGRESSIONAL HEARING
IN DECEMBER TWENTY OH ONE. WHEN
THE SOCIAL SECURITY
ADMINISTRATION'S INSPECTOR
GENERAL WHO NOTED THAT AT LEAST
SEVEN OF THE NINE ELEVEN
HIJACKERS OBTAINED VIRGINIA
STATE IDENTITY CARDS. TO BOARD
PLANES EVEN THOUGH THEY LIVED IN
MARYLAND AT MOTELS SAID IF WE
CAN BE SURE WE'RE INTERACTING
WITH THE RIGHT PERSON. THEN THE
PERSON THAT THEY PURPORT TO BE.
AND WHERE ARE WE- THE DATA
MATCHING IS KEY ONE OF THE
SOLUTIONS TO PREVENT IDENTITY
THEFT IS THE RESPONSIBLE USE OF
INFORMATION TO TELL ONE PERSON
FROM ANOTHER PERSON. REMEMBER
THAT OLD NEW YORKER CARTOON ON
THE INTERNET NO ONE KNOWS YOU'RE
A DOG. THAT STILL APPLIES TODAY
SO HOW DO WE DO THAT ONE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT WAYS TO PROPERLY
IDENTIFY AND AUTHENTICATE
PEOPLE. IS DATA AVAILABILITY AND
DATA MATCHING AND MORE OF IT. IN
JANUARY TWENTY OH ONE- IN
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE
GAO CONCLUDED. THAT IN MANY
CASES FEDERAL AGENCIES THAT
OVERSEE A NUMBER OF INCOME
DEPENDENT BENEFIT PROGRAMS LIKE
ENERGY ASSISTANCE. AND HOUSING
ASSISTANCE MAYBE MISSING
OPPORTUNITIES TO HELP STATE AND
LOCAL AGENCIES ENHANCE THEIR
VERIFICATION TOOLS. DATA
VERIFICATION CAN ENABLE PROGRAMS
TO IDENTIFY POTENTIAL FRAUD. OR
IMPOSTER PAYMENTS. AND IN A
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY TWO PRESS
RELEASE FROM THE NEW YORK
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCIAL
SERVICES. A LARGE INSURANCE
COMPANY ENTERED INTO A
SETTLEMENT WITH THE DEPARTMENT.
FOR ITS FAILURE TO CROSS CHECK
OUT THE SOCIAL SECURITY
ADMINISTRATION'S DEATH MASTER
FILE TO MAKE SURE THE DENTIST
BENEFITS ARE GOING TO THE RIGHT
PEOPLE. NOW LET ME SPEND A
MOMENT TALKING ABOUT THE LOCK.
FEDERAL AND STATE LAW IMPOSES ON
CONSUMER REPORTING AGENCIES OUR
MEMBERS A NUMBER OF OBLIGATIONS
AND EMPOWERS CONSUMERS WITH A
NUMBER OF IMPORTANT RIGHTS TO
PROTECT THEIR INFORMATION.
CREDIT FREEZES CREDIT FREEZES
FOR MINERS TRADE LINE BLOCKING
WHERE CONSUMERS WITH AN ID THEFT
REPORT CAN BLOCK FROM APPEARING
ON A CREDIT REPORT ITEMS THAT
WERE COMPROMISED BY FRAUD. FRAUD
ALERTS FOR ALL CONSUMERS ACTIVE
DUTY ALERTS AND CREDIT REPORTS
FOR OUR ACTIVE DUTY MILITARY
PERSONNEL. SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBER TRYING KISHAN CREDIT
REPORTS CREDIT AND DEBIT CARD
NUMBER TRUNCATION. ESTABLISHMENT
OF RED FLAG GUIDELINES WHERE THE
FEDERAL BANKING AGENCIES AND
LENDERS AND CREDITORS MUST
ESTABLISH GUIDELINES TO PROTECT
PREVENT AND DETECT- TO DETECT
IDENTITY THEFT PATTERNS AND
PREVENT THEM. COMPLAIN
COORDINATION THE FTC AND THE
NATIONAL CREDIT BUREAUS HAVE
MUST HAVE A SYSTEM IN PLACE AND
THEY DO HAVE A SYSTEM IN PLACE
TO COORDINATE CONSUMER
COMPLAINTS. THERE'S A PREVENTION
OF A PROPOSED A PROVISION IN
FEDERAL LAW WHERE COMPANIES TO
FURNISH DATA TO CONSUMER
REPORTING AGENCIES AGAIN OUR
MEMBERS HAVE TO DEVELOP PRISSY
PROCEDURES TO PREVENT. THE
REAPPEARANCE OF DATA THAT WAS
THE SUBJECT OF FRAUD DEBT
COLLECTION LIMITS FOR DEBT
RESULTING IN FRAUD STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS EXCEPTIONS ENHANCED
OPT OUT FOR PRE APPROVED CREDIT
CARD AND INSURANCE OFFICERS.
DISPOSAL OF RECORDS THAT
CONSUMER REPORTING INFORMATION
MUST BE DISPOSED OF AND I'M
MANNER SET BY FEDERAL
REGULATION. ADDRESS
RECONCILIATION WORK CONSUMER
REPORTING AGENCIES MUST NOTIFY
USERS OF CONSUMER REPORTS. ABOUT
SUBSTANTIALLY DIFFERENT
ADDRESSES BETWEEN AN ADDRESS ON
FILE AND AN ADDRESS FROM AN
APPLICANT- THOSE ARE JUST A
NUMBER OF- OF TOOLS USED TO
CHAIR. XI TI MEMBERS. HAVE TOOLS
LIKE I SAID FOR CONSUMERS ARE
VOLUNTARY INITIATIVES AND LEGAL
OBLIGATIONS ALL COMBINE TO HELP
PROTECT AND PREVENT IDENTITY
THEFT THERE'S STILL MORE WORK TO
BE DONE AND OUR MEMBERS ARE
WORKING HARD ON THAT EVERY
SINGLE DAY. AND THERE'S MORE
THAT COULD BE DONE AS WELL LIKE
I SAID YEAH- TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC. IN THE FORM OF SENATE
BILL TWELVE SIXTY TWO BY SENATOR
BRADFORD WHICH CAN ALSO HELP
CONSUMERS WHERE THEY LIVE. AND
WHERE THEY WORK TO HELP KEEP
CALIFORNIANS SAFE EVERYWHERE WE
GO SO WITH THAT- MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I WILL
PAUSE AND I WILL LOOK FORWARD TO
ANSWERING ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MIGHT HAVE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN I NEXT WE
HEAR FROM EVA VELASQUEZ THE
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF THE
IDENTITY THEFT RESOURCE CENTER
WELCOME IS ALASKA'S. THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMEN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND
THANK YOU FOR THE HONOR OF
SPEAKING WITH YOU TODAY. MY NAME
IS EVA VELASQUEZ AND I'M THE CEO
OF THE NONPROFIT IDENTITY THEFT
RESOURCE CENTER BASED IN SAN
DIEGO CALIFORNIA. FOR OVER
TWENTY YEARS WE'VE PROVIDED FREE
SERVICES TO VICTIMS OF IDENTITY
CRIMES IN FACT LAST YEAR OUR
CONTACT CENTER ASSISTED FIFTEEN
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS TO EITHER
RECOVER THEIR IDENTITIES OR
PREPARE FOR THE DAY WHEN THEIR
IDENTITIES ARE REQUIRED OR
MISUSED. AND WE ASSISTED AN
ADDITIONAL ONE MILLION PEOPLE
THROUGH OUR WEBSITE NOW REACH
PROGRAMS ALL AT NO COST TO THEM
. I'D LIKE TO START BY CLEARING
UP SOME CONFUSION AROUND
IDENTITY THEFT VERSUS IDENTITY
FRAUD. IDENTITY THEFT OCCURS
WHEN OUR IDENTITY CREDENTIALS
AND ARE PERSONALLY IDENTIFYING
INFORMATION ARE COMPROMISED IN
SOME WAY SOMETIMES IT'S THROUGH
SELF COMPROMISE WHEN WE SHARE IT
WITH SOMEONE WHO SHOULDN'T HAVE
IT MAYBE IT'S THROUGH A PHISHING
EMAIL OR A SCAM PHONE CALL. OR
IT CAN BE COMPROMISED YOUR DATA
BREACH. THERE WERE ONE THOUSAND
EIGHT HUNDRED AND SIXTY TWO DATA
BREACHES LAST YEAR IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THE HIGHEST NUMBER
WE'VE RECORDED SINCE WE STARTED
TRACKING THESE EVENTS BACK IN
TWO THOUSAND FIVE. AND IT'S THE
STUFF OF OUR DATA THAT'S FUELING
THE IDENTITY FRAUD EPIDEMIC.
IDENTITY THEFT AND FRAUD OCCURS
AND ALL OF OUR SYSTEMS WE'VE
ALREADY MENTIONED FINANCIAL. AND
GOVERNMENT BUT YOUR IDENTITY
CANNOT ONLY BE USED TO TAKE OUT
LOANS AND OR CREDIT CARDS OR TO
APPLY FOR GOVERNMENT BENEFITS
AND SERVICES THAT CAN ALSO BE
USED DURING THE COMMISSION OF A
CRIME. OR EVEN FOR MEDICAL GOODS
AND SERVICES THINGS LIKE A
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS AND DURABLE
MEDICAL EQUIPMENT SH AND
ADDITIONALLY IDENTITY FRAUD CAN
CO OCCUR WITH OTHER CRIME TYPES.
AN EXAMPLE OF THIS WOULD BE A
DOMESTIC ABUSERS AND HUMAN
TRAFFIC PERSONAL USE IDENTITY
CREDENTIALS OF THEIR VICTIMS TO
EITHER FURTHER CONTROL THEM OR
TO FURTHER FUND THEIR OTHER
CRIMINAL ENTERPRISES. ACCORDING
TO THE FTC TWENTY TWENTY ONE
CONSUMER SENTINEL NETWORK DATA
BOOK IDENTITY THEFT WAS THE
NUMBER ONE TYPE OF FRAUD
COMPLAINTS IN THE COUNTRY AS
WELL AS ON THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SH IDENTITY FRAUD OR
IDENTITY RELATED. FRAUD
COMPLAINTS ACCOUNTED 425% OF ALL
THE FRAUD COMPLAINTS IN THE
STATE. AND ACCORDING TO PRIVATE
RESEARCH ENTITIES THOUGH THOSE
ANNUAL NATIONAL NUMBERS ARE MUCH
HIGHER OFTEN IN THE TENS OF
MILLIONS OF VICTIMS ANNUALLY
WITH THE LOSSES IN TWENTY TWENTY
ESTIMATED. TO BE AT FIFTY SIX
BILLION. BUT IF WE ONLY. THE
DOLLAR LOSSES WE FAIL TO SEE THE
FULL IMPACT IMPACT OF IDENTITY
CRIMES THERE'S OFTEN THIS
CASCADING EFFECT THAT IMPACTS
ALL FACETS OF THE VICTIM'S LIFE.
AND THERE ARE A MOTIONAL THE
PHYSICAL EVEN LOST OPPORTUNITY
COSTS THAT COSTS THAT WE DON'T
OFTEN CONSIDER. SINCE TWO
THOUSAND THREE THE I. KERR SEES
BUT MEASURING THESE IMPACTS ON
OUR AFTERMATH REPORTS. THIS IS A
SURVEY WHERE WE TALK TO THE
VICTIMS THAT WE ASSISTED IN THE
PREVIOUS YEAR AND WE ASK THEM
THESE QUESTIONS. IN OUR REPORT
ISSUED LAST YEAR 84% OF PRE
PANDEMIC VICTIMS REPORTED
FEELING ANXIOUS AND WORRIED. 76%
FELT VIOLATED. AND A FULL 10%
HAD SUICIDAL THOUGHTS. SINCE THE
PANDEMIC 40% OF OUR RESPONDENTS
STATED THEY WERE UNABLE TO PAY
THEIR ROUTINE BILLS 33% DID NOT
HAVE ENOUGH MONEY FOR FOOD OR
UTILITIES FOR BASIC NECESSITIES.
AND 13% OF OUR RESPONDENTS SAID
THEY WERE UNABLE TO GET A
TEMPORARY OR TEMPORARY OR A
PERMANENT JOB AS A RESULT OF AN
IDENTITY MISUSE. VICTIMS OFTEN
EQUATE THEIR EXPERIENCE- BUT-
LIKE A MEDICAL DIAGNOSIS WHERE
IT CAN GO INTO REMISSION BUT
IT'S NEVER FULLY CARED BECAUSE
OUR RECOVERY PROCESSES ARE SO
INCONSISTENT THEY'RE CONFUSING
AND SOMETIMES THEY'RE EVEN AN
ACCESSIBLE. THEY THEY JUST
AREN'T UNIFORM. EVERY ENTITY
WHERE IDENTITY FRAUD CANON DOES
OCCUR FROM BANKS TO GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES TO MEDICAL PROVIDERS
HAS A DIFFERENT PROCESS THAT THE
VICTIMS MUST BE KNOWLEDGEABLE
ABOUT IT MUST EXECUTE ON. ANY OF
NUMEROUS SYSTEMS ARE LEVERAGED
TO COMMIT THE CRIME THE VICTIM
MUST RESOLVE THAT ISSUE WITH
EACH AND EVERY ENTITY
INDIVIDUALLY. IT'S UNREASONABLE
FOR US TO EXPECT VICTIMS TO KNOW
HOW TO PRIORITIZE AND CONTACT
EACH ORGANIZATION ON THEIR OWN
OUR OUR RECOVERY AND RISK
MINIMIZATION SERVICES FOR
VICTIMS ARE NOT APPROPRIATELY
PRIORITIZED. DESPITE THE GROWING
VOLUME OF IDENTITY CRIMES AND
THE INCREASE IN RESOURCES
DEDICATED TO ADDRESSING THE ROOT
CAUSES OF CYBER CRIMES WHICH IS
VERY VERY IMPORTANT. THERE IS NO
SIMILAR EFFORT UNDER WAY TO
SUPPORT THE ACTUAL VICTIMS OF
THESE CRIMES. PAID SERVICES ARE
AVAILABLE BUT MANY PEOPLE CAN'T
AFFORD THEM THEY'RE THEY'RE OUT
OF REACH FOR MANY FOLKS IN THE
GENERAL PUBLIC SO FREE
ASSISTANCE IS AN ABSOLUTE
NECESSITY FOR VICTIMS. AND THERE
ARE ONLY TWO NATIONAL
ORGANIZATIONS THAT PROVIDE THAT
FREE DIRECT ASSISTANCE THAT'S
THE FEDERAL TRADE COMMISSION AND
THE IDENTITY THEFT RESOURCE
CENTER. ABOUT REPORTS THAT I
REFERENCED- AFTERMATH REPORT THE
DATA BREACH NUMBERS- ALL OF
THESE ARE AVAILABLE TO THE
PUBLIC AS WELL AS ALL OF OUR
RECOVERY ASSISTANCE AND
EDUCATIONAL DOCUMENTS. I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND ATTENTION
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO ANSWERING
ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU HAVE.
THANK YOU MS ALASKA'S FOR
SHARING YOUR TIME IS VALUABLE
EXPERTISE. WHEN I LOOK FORWARD
TO THE NEXT PANEL PICK BACK UP
WITH THE MR RAHMAN IN MIS
ALASKA'S- AT THE CLOSE OF THIS
HEARING DURING QUESTION ANSWER-
PANEL TO DISCUSS IDENTITY THEFT
PREVENTION RESPONSE AND
ENFORCEMENT EFFORTS. WILL NOW
BEGIN WITH. A WITH A FIRST I'D
LIKE TO WELCOME TANYA AUSTIN
CALIFORNIA DEPUTY ATTORNEY
GENERAL I THANK YOU MISS US AND
SO MUCH FOR JOINING US. IT'S MY
PLEASURE THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME. I'M A DEPUTY ATTORNEY
GENERAL AND A LINE PROSECUTOR
WHO HAS BEEN WORKING WITH THE
STATE FOR TWENTY PLUS YEARS. AND
FOR BETTER OR WORSE I'VE BEEN
WORKING AND WHAT I CALL PRIVACY
VIOLATION CRIMES FOR THAT TWENTY
YEARS- WE OUGHT TO USE THE TERM
IDENTITY THEFT AS A CATCH ALL.
BUT I. WHEN I WAS WORKING
DIRECTLY WITH- THEN GENERAL
HARRIS. ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE WOULD DISCUSS WAS OFTEN HOW
WORDS CAN MAKE A REALLY BIG
DIFFERENCE AND THAT WAS WHEN WE
WERE TALKING ABOUT IDENTITY
THEFT. AND HOW IT IMPACTED
REVENGE PORN. BUT MOVING ON TO-
FOCUSING ON PRIVACY VIOLATIONS
FROM A CRIMINAL PERSPECTIVE- BY
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL HAS A UNIT
CALLED THE U. CRIMES UNIT WHICH
IS A VERY SPECIAL- SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERTISE CRIMINAL
PROSECUTION UNIT THAT COVERS THE
ENTIRE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WITH
SUBJECT MATTER MATTER EXPERTS
SUCH AS MYSELF WHO SPECIALIZE IN
THE PROSECUTION OF ALL TYPES OF
IDENTITY THEFT CRIMES. AND AS I
SAID WE COVER THE ENTIRE STATE
AT THERE'S ONLY SIX OF US. I'D
LIKE TO THINK THAT- WERE SMALL
BUT MIGHTY. AND WE DO OUR VERY
BEST TO WORK ON COMPLEX- MULTI
JURISDICTIONAL IDENTITY THEFT
CASES. AS WELL AS THE CYBER
CRIMES THAT OFTEN ARE
INTERTWINED WITH THEM. I IN
CONJUNCTION WEST OF THE REGIONAL
HIGH TAX IDENTITY THEFT TASK
FORCES THAT WE HAVE THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WHICH
ARE RUN BY A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT ORGANIZATIONS IN SAN
DIEGO WHERE I'M LOCATED- WE HAVE
TO CATCH I AM ABSOLUTELY SURE-
MISSED ALASKA'S IS FAMILIAR WITH
WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT. AND THAT
IS OUR LOCAL REGIONAL TASK
FORCE. THAT WORKS TO BRING UP
MULTIPLE AGENCIES TOGETHER IN
CONJUNCTION. WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE. TO TRY
TRIP TO TRY TO ATTACK YOU KNOW
STREAM PRICE. AND WHEN I CAN
SHARE WITH YOU TODAY IS THAT
OVER THE YEARS AS A STREET LEVEL
OR NOT IS A STREET LEVEL BUT A
LINE LEVEL PROSECUTING TANK IS
THAT WHEN I STARTED IN THE WORLD
OF PROSECUTING IDENTITY THEFT- I
WOULD INVEST QUITE A BIT OF TIME
WORKING WITH THE COMMUNITY.
TRYING TO EDUCATE INDIVIDUALS ON
HOW TO PROTECT THEIR IDENTITY
AND MISTER CHAIR YOU REALLY
NAILED IT WHEN YOU EMPHASIZE THE
FACT THAT NOW IN THIS DAY AND
AGE IT'S MORE ABOUT WHAT TO DO
AFTER YOUR IDENTITY HAS ACTUALLY
BEEN FISHED OUT OF THE WAY OUR
SITE FOR USE I BET I WOULD SAY
OVERWHELMINGLY. BASED ON MY
PRACTICAL AND ANECDOTAL
EXPERIENCE- EVERY SINGLE
INDIVIDUAL I KNOW HAS HAD THEIR
IDENTITY COMPROMISED IN SOME WAY
OR ANOTHER. AND SO IT'S LESS
ABOUT PREVENTING WELL NOT NOT TO
GIVE UP HOPE. BUT IT'S MORE
ABOUT HOW DO WE HELP OUR
CITIZENS WHEN. THEY HAVE BEEN
PLUCKED FROM THE PILE IN THE
MIDDLE MILLIONS OF IDENTITIES
THAT HAVE BEEN STOLEN OR
COMPROMISED. FOR A CRIMINAL.
VIOLATE AND USED TO GET MONEY
WHICH IS OVERWHELMINGLY THE
ENTIRE PURPOSE BEHIND ALL FORMS
OF IDENTITY THEFT. WHEN I
STARTED I WAS TRADITIONALLY
PROSECUTING INDIVIDUALS WHO
UNFORTUNATELY I SUFFERED FROM
VARIOUS ADDICTIONS STALL
INDIVIDUALS- MAILS OUT MAIL OUT
OF THEIR MAILBOXES- AND DID WHAT
WE CALLED CUTTING CHECKS AND
THINGS OF THAT NATURE. TO
ESSENTIALLY STEAL WHAT MIGHT BE
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS RELATED. TO
AN INDIVIDUAL'S IDENTITY. THE
CLASSIC CASE I NOW CHRIST. AND
BY CLASSIC I MEAN COMMENT IT IS
A VERY SIMILAR TO THE STUDENT
LOAN FRAUD CASE THAT WE JUST-
COMPLETED A GRAND JURY ON IN
ORANGE COUNTY- WHEREIN VARIOUS
BOILER ROOMS ARE USING SOCIAL
ENGINEERING. TO TRICK CITIZENS
INTO PROVIDING THEIR PERSONAL
IDENTIFYING INFORMATION SO THAT
THEY CAN ACCESS THEIR STUDENT
LOANS. AND MANIPULATE THOSE
LOANS AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. AND STEAL MONEY FROM
THE STUDENT BORROWERS TO THE
TUNE OF WHAT TURNED OUT TO BE
OVER SIX MILLION DOLLARS WITH
THE VICTIM'S DATA DAYS OF
SIXTEEN THOUSAND VICTIMS. THAT'S
ONE VERY SIMPLE EXAMPLE THAT SET
US SEVEN CODEFENDANT CRIMINAL
CASE NOW ACTIVE IN IN SANTA ANA
YOU KNOW IN ORANGE COUNTY-
WHERE- TRYING TO MANAGE THESE
VERY VERY COMPLEX IDENTITY THEFT
SCHEMES. THAT INVOLVED THOUSANDS
UPON THOUSANDS OF VICTIMS WERE
OFTEN TIMES THE GOAL IS TO STEAL
SMALL AMOUNTS OF MONEY FROM A
LOT OF PEOPLE BECAUSE IT'S VERY
VERY EASY TO DO WITH OUR
INTERNET AGE WORLD. IS WHITE
POINTS SUCH AN INCREDIBLE-
RESOURCE STRAIN ON YOUR JUST
YOUR GENERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
TEAM AND PROSECUTORS. THERE WAS
A TIME YEARS AGO WHEN I WOULD
CITE THE STATISTIC WHERE IN I
WOULD SHARE WITH INDIVIDUALS
THAT IT WOULD TAKE ABOUT FORTY
TO FIFTY MAN HOURS TO
INVESTIGATE YOUR AVERAGE
HOMICIDE. OKAY NOW AGAIN THERE'S
NO SUCH THING AS AN AVERAGE
HOMICIDE BUT MY POINT BEING THAT
AT THE TIME PUTTING TOGETHER AN
AVERAGE IDENTITY THEFT
INVESTIGATION WAS BEING CLOCKED
AT TWO HUNDRED ONE FOR SEVEN
HOURS. SO PUTTING THOSE TWO
TOGETHER AND LOOKING AT HOW THAT
IMPACTS OUR ABILITY TO ACTUALLY
KIND OF STOP CRIME ON THE STREET
SPECIALLY WHEN IT'S RISEN TO
THIS LEVEL OF EXTREME
SOPHISTICATION. SHOWS THAT- YOU
KNOW THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT IN TRYING
TO BRING TO BEAR THE
SOPHISTICATION TO MANAGE THOSE
PARTICULAR PROBLEMS. IS OFTEN
CAN HONORED BY THE OVERALL.
STRUGGLE OF BEING ABLE TO HAVE
THE RESOURCES AGAIN AS I MISSED
THE LAST HAS COMMENTED IN EVEN
JUST ASSISTING OUR VICTIMS ON A
CASE SO- WITH THAT I ALWAYS
SERVE ANY FURTHER COMMENTARY AND
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENING
IN THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
AND- WHAT TYPES OF TOOLS WERE
USING AND WHAT TYPES OF TOLS WE
CAN USE. AS WE MOVE FORWARD I'M
TRYING TO COMBAT THIS VERY
INSIDIOUS A CRIMINAL ACTIVITY
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
SO MUCH MISS AUSTIN FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY AND FOR YOUR WORK ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND OUR RESIDENTS.
LAST BUT NOT LEAST CERTAINLY
WILL HEAR FROM GERMANY GRANT THE
MANAGING DIRECTOR OF TECHNOLOGY
BUSINESS STRATEGY AT VENABLE L.
L. P. MR GRANT THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US. RIGHT THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY.
MISTER CHAIRMAN CHAIRMAN HERE IN
YOUR OPENING STATEMENT I THOUGHT
IT HIGHLIGHTED A CRITICAL
QUESTION THAT DOES NOT GET
ENOUGH ATTENTION IN THESE
DISCUSSIONS WHICH IS. KNOWING
WHAT WE KNOW. WHY DO WE CONTINUE
TO BUILD SECURITY SYSTEMS WITH
THE OUTDATED ASSUMPTION THAT
HAVING KNOWLEDGE OF Y IDENTITY
INFORMATION MEANS I'M SOMEHOW
THAT PERSON. MY NAME'S JEREMY
GRANTHAM MANAGING DIRECTOR IN
THE CYBER SECURITY PRACTICE
AVAILABLE I'M BASED OUT OF
WASHINGTON DC. CREDIBLE ALSO HAS
A BIG PRESENCE IN BOTH LA AND
SAN FRANCISCO. AS BACKGROUND
I'VE WORKED FOR MORE THAN TWENTY
YEARS ACROSS BOTH INDUSTRY AND
GOVERNMENT AT THE INTERSECTION
OF IDENTITY AND SECURITY.
INCLUDING SEVERAL YEARS LEADING
THE TRUSTED IDENTITIES GROUP
THAT NASTY NATIONAL INSTITUTE OF
STANDARDS AND TECHNOLOGY. AS
PART OF MY ROLE IN VENABLE I
LEAD AN ORGANIZATION CALLED THE
BETTER IDENTITY COALITION WAS
LAUNCHED IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN IN
THE WAKE OF MASSIVE. TAX BREACH
IT'S BEEN FOCUSED ON BRINGING
TOGETHER LEADING FIRMS FROM
DIFFERENT SECTORS TO WORK WITH
POLICYMAKERS TO IMPROVE THE WAY
THAT AMERICANS ESTABLISH AND
PROTECT AND VERIFY THEIR
IDENTITIES WHEN THEY'RE ONLINE.
OUR MEMBERS INCLUDE RECOGNIZED
LEADERS FROM FIRMS IN FINANCIAL
SERVICES TELECOM HEALTHCARE
TECHNOLOGY INTACT INSURANCE
PAYMENTS AND SECURITY RE TWENTY
SEVEN MEMBERS ARE UNITED BY A
COMMON RECOGNITION. BUT THE WAY
WE HANDLE IDENTITY TODAY IN THE
U. S. IS BROKEN. BY COMMON
DESIRE TO SEE BOTH THE PUBLIC
AND PRIVATE SECTORS EACH TAKES
STEP TO MAKE STEPS MAKE IDENTITY
SYSTEMS WORK BETTER. UP FRONT I
WANT TO SAY THE WAY WE HANDLE
IDENTITY IN THIS COUNTRY IMPACTS
OUR SECURITY OUR PRIVACY AND OUR
LIBERTY FROM AN ECONOMIC
STANDPOINT PARTICULARS WERE
LOOKING TO MOVE MORE HIGH VALUE
TRANSACTIONS INTO THE DIGITAL
WORLD. IDENTITY CAN BE THE GREAT
ENABLER PROVIDING THE FOUNDATION
FOR DIGITAL TRANSACTIONS AND
ONLINE EXPERIENCES THAT ARE MORE
SECURE. MORE ENJOYABLE FOR THE
USER AND IDEALLY MORE RESPECTFUL
OF THEIR PRIVACY. WHEN WE DON'T
GET IDENTITY RIGHT WE NEED A
LIST OF GREAT ATTACK POINTS FOR
CRIMINALS AND OTHER ADVERSARIES.
A WHOPPING 81% OF CYBER SECURITY
ATTACKS ARE EXECUTED BY TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF WEAK OR STOLEN
PASSWORDS. 81% SAID ENORMOUS
NUMBER IT MEANS IT IS AN ANOMALY. WHEN A BREACH. HE HAS NOT
PROVIDED EXPECTED. DON'T OF
PASSWORDS WHICH ADVERSE STICKY
JUST TELL ME DATA SETS OF A- IN
LARGE PARTS EVEN EASIER TIME
COMPROMISING THE ID VERIFICATION
SERVICES TO BUSINESSES PUT IN
PLACE THE BEST APPLICANTS FOR
NEW CREDIT CARDS OR OTHER
SERVICES IN WHICH GOVERNMENTS
LIKE CALIFORNIA USED ABOUT
APPLICANTS FOR STATE
ADMINISTERED BENEFITS PROGRAMS
SUCH AS UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE.
I KNOW THIS LAST AREAS GOTTEN
QUITE A BIT OF ATTENTION
CALIFORNIA PAST YEAR WITH
REPORTS THE TWENTY BILLION
DOLLARS MIGHT HAVE BEEN PAID OUT
TO CRIMINALS POLICE NOT POSING
AS CALIFORNIANS. OUTSIDE OF FOR
OTHER STORIES ON THE FLIP SIDE
OF CALIFORNIANS HAVE BEEN UNABLE
TO GET THE UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS
THEY NEED AND RIGHTFULLY DESERVE
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T PROVE THEY
ARE ONLINE AND IN SOME CASES THE
SOME OF THE SAME PEOPLE ARE NOW
GETTING THE TEN NINETY NINE G.
TAX FORMS ABOUT TAXES OBEY ON
BENEFITS OF CRIMINAL CLAIM
BEFORE. THEM WHICH IS JUST
ADDING INSULT TO INJURY. THE
SAME SERIES EVENTS. HAS BEEN
REPEATED IN DOZENS OF STATES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY THESE PAST
FEW YEARS. AS ORGANIZED
CRIMINALS RACE TO EXPLOIT WEAK
ID VERIFICATION SYSTEMS TO STEAL
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS. SO WHY DOES
THIS KEEP HAPPENING. WELL I
THINK A KEY TAKEAWAY FOR THE
COMMITTEE TO UNDERSTAND TODAY'S
THE ATTACKERS HAVE JUST. FLAT
OUT CAUGHT UP WITH A LOT OF THE
FIRST GENERATION TOOLS WE'VE
USED TO PROTECT. AND VERIFY AND
AUTHENTICATE IDENTITY. SO
THERE'S A LOT OF REASONS FOR
THIS AND MAYBE A LITTLE BIT OF
BLAME TO ALLOCATE BUT THE MOST
IMPORTANT QUESTION IS. WHAT
SHOULD GOVERNMENT AND INDUSTRY
DO ABOUT IT NOW. THAT'S A KEY
POINT TO GOVERNMENT AND INDUSTRY
IF THERE'S ONE MESSAGE I'D LIKE
THE COMMITTEE TO TAKE AWAY FROM
TODAY'S HEARING. IS THAT
INDUSTRY IS SAYING THEY CAN'T
SOLVE THIS ALONE. AWARDED
JUNCTURE WHERE THE GOVERNMENT IS
GOING TO NEED TO STEP UP AND
PLAY A BIGGER ROLE. TO HELP
ADDRESS CRITICAL VULNERABILITIES
IN OUR DIGITAL IDENTITIES
FABRIC. IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN TO
BETTER IDENTITY COALITION
PUBLISHED WILL BE CALLED OUR
POLICY BLUEPRINTS WHICH
OUTLINED. A SET OF KEY
INITIATIVES THE GOVERNMENT
SHOULD LAUNCH TO IMPROVE
IDENTITY THAT ARE BOTH
MEANINGFUL IMPACT AND- WE THINK
PRACTICAL IMPLEMENTS. NOW THIS
ISN'T ABOUT A NATIONAL ID WE'RE
NOT RECOMMENDING THE ONE BE
CREATED. OUR THESIS IS REALLY
THAT WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED
AUTHORITATIVE GOVERNMENTS AND
IDENTITY SYSTEMS ALREADY TODAY.
THE DRIVER'S LICENSE A BIRTH
CERTIFICATE OR PASSPORT THE
SSNS. ARE CHALLENGERS WHAT I
CALL THE IDENTITY GAP. WHICH IS
ALL THE SYSTEMS ARE STUCK OVER
THE PAPER WORLD WHILE. COMMERCE
IS INCREASINGLY MOVING ONLINE.
SO TO FIX THIS AMERICA'S. BASE.
ASK AN AGENCY. THAT ALREADY
ISSUED THEM A CREDENTIAL TO
STAND BEHIND IT IN THE ONLINE
WORLD BY VALIDATING THE
INFORMATION FROM THAT
CREDENTIAL. HERE'S WHERE STATES
LIKE CALIFORNIA CAN PLAY A ROLE.
BY SHIFTING FROM ISSUING
DRIVER'S LICENSES AND STATE ID
EAST THAT ARE JUST PLASTIC
CARDS. BUT ALSO DOUBLE AS ROBUST
DIGITAL CREDENTIALS SAY BY
LETTING CONSUMERS CHOOSE TO
STORE DIGITAL VERSION OF THEIR
DRIVER'S LICENSE OR SMART PHONE.
WE FUNDED THE VERY FIRST PILOTS
OF THESE NEW MOBILE DRIVER'S
LICENSES BACK WHEN I WAS A
FINISHED IN TWENTY TWELVE. TODAY
A NUMBER OF STATES HAVE EMBRACED
HIM AS THE BEST WAY TO EXTEND
THE TRUST MODEL OF THE STATE
DRIVER'S LICENSE TO THE ONLINE
WORLD. THERE'S NOT A SINGLE
ENTITY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IN MY VIEW PUBLIC OR
PRIVATE THAT'S BETTER SUITED TO
HELP SOLVE THIS PROBLEM IN THE
DMV. IF CALIFORNIA HAD A MOBILE
DRIVER'S LICENSE PROGRAM IN
PLACE AT THE START OF A
PANDEMIC. STATE OFFICIALS COULD
LEVERAGE THE MILLIONS OF STATE
BACKED IDENTITY PROOFING PROCESS
THESE. CALIFORNIANS ARE ALREADY
GONE THROUGH THIS DMV OFFICES TO
VALIDATE. THE IDENTITIES OF
APPLICANTS FOR UNEMPLOYMENT. NOW
TO BE CLEAR THAT MEANS MOST
APPLICANTS ARE NOT ALL. THE
DRIVER'S LICENSE MIGHT BE THE
MOST COMMONLY HELD EXPOSURE-
HIGH ASSURANCE IDENTITY
CREDENTIAL IN CALIFORNIA. BUT
THERE ARE THOUSANDS OF ADULTS IN
THE STATES YOU DON'T HAVE ONE.
AND THERE'S NO DOUBT THERE'S
GONNA BE SOME PEOPLE WHO WILL
WANT TO STATE ISSUED APP ON A
SMARTPHONE OR ONE ON A
SMARTPHONE. SO MOBILE DRIVER'S
LICENSE CAN BE PART OF THE
SOLUTION IT CAN'T BE THE ONLY
SOLUTION OTHERWISE SHOULD BE
EXCLUDING A LOT OF PEOPLE FROM
ACCESS TO SERVICES. SHOWS A
STARTING POINT I THINK IT'S THE
MOST LOGICAL PLACE FOR
CALIFORNIA FOCUS. ALSO HELP TO
SHIFT US BEYOND OUTDATED SYSTEMS
THAT REMIND IDENTIFIERS LIKE THE
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER WHICH
HAVE BEEN COMPROMISED. SO
FREQUENTLY THAT THEY NO LONGER
HAVE ANY SECURITY VALUE AT ALL.
THE IDEA THAT SIMPLY KNOWING
SOMEBODY'S SSN IS EVIDENCE THAT
YOU ARE THAT PERSON IS WILDLY
UPDATE. THE REALITY IS MOST SSNS
HAVE BEEN COMPROMISED IN ONE OR
MORE DATA BREACHES OVER THE LAST
TEN YEARS. SO BOTH INDUSTRY AND
GOVERNMENT SHOULD BE BUILDING
SYSTEMS. THAT ASSUME. SHOULD NOT
BE THE ONLY SYSTEM THAT ASSUME
THAT SYSTEMS ARE SECRET. OR HAVE
ANY SECURITY VALUE BECAUSE TODAY
THEY DON'T. KNOW THAT DOESN'T
MEAN THAT THE SS AND DOESN'T
HAVE ANY IMPORTANT ROLE TO PLAY
AND IDENTITY. AT THE END OF THE
DAY I DIE AS THE ASSISTANT AS AN
IDENTIFIER AWAY FOR EXAMPLE TO
HELP SOMEONE DETERMINED IF.
SOMEBODY NAMED JEREMY GRANT IS
APPLYING FOR AN ACCOUNT. AND
THERE'S MAYBE THREE HUNDRED
GERMAN GRANTS THAT THEY CAN SEE
IN THE SYSTEM WELL. WHICH JEREMY
GRANTED SEE ONLY ONE. HOPEFULLY
AS MY ASSISTANT. I DON'T NEED TO
BE SECRET THE FACT OTHER
COMMONLY USED IDENTIFIERS LIKE
PHONE NUMBERS AND EMAIL
ADDRESSES ARE NOT. BUT WE
SOMEHOW BECOME FIXATED AS A
COUNTRY AND THE CONCEPT OF THE
ASSISTANT CAN AND SHOULD BE A
SECRET. AND CONTINUE TO FOCUS
OUR SEASON SECURITY EFFORTS.
AROUND WHAT'S UNFORTUNATE
BECOMING OUTDATED CONCEPT.
RATHER THAN FOCUS ON NEWER
INITIATIVES THAT MIGHT BETTER
PROTECT AMERICANS IN THE
SECURITY AND PRIVACY OF THEIR
DATA. SO WITH ALL THIS IN MIND
I'M REALLY GLAD TO SEE THE
SENATE HOLDING THIS HEARING
TODAY. AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
ANSWERING YOUR QUESTIONS THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER GRANT. REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR TESTIMONY AND- I BEFORE I
MOVE ON TO A NUMBER OF QUESTIONS
AND COMMENTS I DID WANT TO AGAIN
INVITE THE PUBLIC WANTING TO
PARTICIPATE THE CALL IN NOW.
PLEASE DIAL THIS TOLL FREE
NUMBER. 844-291-6364 AND WHEN
PROMPTED PLEASE USE THIS ACCESS
CODE. SEVEN SIX NINE SEVEN ONE
EIGHT EIGHT. WELL NOW BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO MEMBERS FOR
QUESTIONS I THINK WHAT I'D LIKE
TO DO IS THIS- I'LL OPEN UP A
FEW QUESTIONS FOR OUR FIRST
PANEL- THEN I'LL MOVE IT TO MY
COLLEAGUES- IF THEY HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FOR EITHER ANY OF THE
PANELISTS- AND THEN I WILL
RETURN BACK TO THE PANEL TO- WE
CAN THEN TAKE IT BACK TO THE
PANEL- THE MEMBERS IF THEY HAVE
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS AT THAT
POINT- GOING BACK TO MR ELMAN
AND MISS ALASKA'S. I GUESS MY
FIRST QUESTION FOR BOTH OF YOU
IS JUST TO GET A SENSE OF THE
SCALE OF THE PROBLEM- YOU KNOW
WE HAVE- WE DO HAVE SOME
ANECDOTES HERE AROUND- THE SCALE
OF IDENTITY THEFT AND IDENTITY
FRAUD- YOU KNOW WE HEARD FROM
MISTER GRANT THAT HE THINKS AT
THIS POINT MOST PEOPLE HAD THEIR
ASSETS AND- BREACHED IN SOME WAY
OR ANOTHER- DO YOU HAVE ANY DATA
OR INFORMATION THAT WOULD GIVE
YOU A SENSE OF. HOW BIG A
PROBLEM WE'RE TALKING ABOUT AT
THIS POINT. WELL I WOULD YIELD
TO MY COLLEAGUE MISTER LAST
CHRISTMAS- WHO MAY HAVE CLOSER
FAMILIARITY WITH THOSE NUMBERS
AND WE DO- YES WE DO HAVE DATA
ON PARTICULARLY ON DATA BREACHES
THE I. TERZI HAS BEEN CAPTURING
A PUBLICLY REPORTED. INCIDENTS
SINCE TWO THOUSAND FIVE AND WE
DO ISSUE A REPORT ON THAT- WE
CAPTURE THE NUMBER NOT ONLY OF
INCIDENTS THERE WERE ONE
THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED AND SIXTY
TWO BACK IN- LAST YEAR. A BUT WE
ALSO LOOK AT THE NUMBER OF
VICTIMS NOT THE NUMBER OF
RECORDS THOSE ARE IN THE
TRILLIONS BUT THE ACTUAL NUMBER
OF INDIVIDUALS THAT WERE
IMPACTED I CAN LOOK THAT NUMBER
UP I DON'T HAVE IT IN FRONT OF
ME AT THE MOMENT BUT IT HAS BEEN
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS HUNDREDS
OF MILLIONS OF VICTIMS SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND FIVE THE STATEMENT
THAT ALL OF OUR INFORMATION IS
ALREADY COMPROMISED PARTICULARLY
OUR SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBERS
BASED ON THE DATA THAT WE'VE
SEEN WE WOULD HAVE TO AGREE WITH
THAT- THE ONLY INDIVIDUALS WHOSE
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBERS HAVE NOT
YET BEEN COMPROMISED IN THIS
COUNTRY ARE THE ONES THAT
HAVEN'T BEEN. ISSUED THOSE
NUMBERS YET. AND IN FACT. WE ARE
SEEING THIEVES USE ODD NUMBERS
THAT THEY'VE JUST MADE UP. AND
THESE NUMBERS ARE ALREADY
TAINTED WHEN THEY ARE ISSUED SO.
MY RESPONSE TO THAT WOULD BE YES
WE HAVE THE DATA I'M HAPPY TO
PROVIDE THAT REPORT. AND THE
SCALE OF IT IS ON TENABLE RIGHT
NOW THE SYSTEM IS BROKEN. AND
ALL OF OUR DATA AT LEAST A
CRITICAL FOUNDATIONAL IDENTITY
DATA AND THEY THEN THE P. I. R.
THAT'S NECESSARY TO PERPETRATE
IDENTITY CRIMES HAS LARGELY BEEN
COMPROMISED IN PREVIOUS DATA
BREACHES. THANK YOU MISS WEST
COAST AND I GUESS AS A FOLLOW UP
TO THAT- HOW MUCH OF THIS IS
DOMESTIC SORT OF LIKE PETTY
CRIMINALS AND I THINK FROM SOME
OF YOUR TESTIMONIES. WE HEARD
THAT A LOT OF THIS IS LOW
HANGING FRUIT IT'S LIKE LOW
LEVEL IDENTITY THEFT IDENTITY
FRAUD- BUT WE ALSO HEARD
ANECDOTALLY AND SEEN REPORTS OF
A MAJOR DATA BREACHES COMING
FROM FOREIGN HACKERS. AND TRY TO
GET A SENSE OF WHAT'S THE SCALE
AND THEN AS A FOLLOW UP QUESTION
IS THAT- YOU KNOW YOU'D HAVE
JUST STARTED TO IMPOSE SOME
RATHER CRIPPLING SANCTIONS ON.
RUSSIA AND I THINK AT THIS POINT
WE'VE ALREADY SEEN EVIDENCE THAT
THE AMOUNT OF RUSSIAN HACKER
ACTIVITY HAS HAS DROPPED PRETTY
DRAMATICALLY IN THE LAST COUPLE
DAYS. DO WE THINK THAT THIS WILL
HAVE ANY IMPACT ON HACKING
COPPERHEADS GIVING FOREIGN
ADVERSARIES MORE YOU KNOW
AMBITION TO TRY TO GO AFTER U.
S. CONSUMERS. ARE PERHAPS LESS
RESOURCES AND ABILITY TO ACCESS
US CONSUMERS TO HAVE A SENSE OF
A SUSPECT THIS WHAT WE'RE SEEING
RIGHT NOW. WITH THE GLOBAL
STAGES CAN IMPACT IDENTITY THEFT
IN ANY WAY SHAPE OR FORM HERE IN
THE UNITED STATES. MR CHAIRMAN
LET ME TRY AND THAT A COUPLE OF
WAYS IF I MAY FIRST- I DON'T
HAVE A LOT OF. DATA THAT WOULD
SUPPORT PERCENTAGES OF WHO'S
DOING THE ATTACKING PROVIDE. I
THINK THERE'S A COUPLE OF
POINTS. THAT ARE IMPORTANT FOR
THE COMMITTEE TO KNOW FIRST. IS
THAT IDENTITY THEFT AND CYBER
SECURITY INTRUSIONS. COME FROM A
VARIETY OF DIFFERENT SOURCES ON.
THE BIGGEST AND GRANDEST SCALE
THEY ARE COMING FROM STATE
ACTORS LIKE CHINA AND RUSSIA AND
NORTH KOREA FOR EXAMPLE. AND
THAT MAKES IT PARTICULARLY HARD
TO LOCATE AN ADDRESS BUT IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT AND IT HAS TO
HAPPEN AND IT DOES. BUT WE'VE
ALSO SEEN THAT MANY BUSINESSES
ARE AT RISK FOR IT INSIDERS
AFTER IN FACT THERE'S BEEN DATA
THAT I'VE SEEN RECENTLY THAT
SHOWS SMALL BUSINESSES. IN
PARTICULAR ARE PARTICULARLY
VULNERABLE BECAUSE THEY DON'T
NECESSARILY INVEST. ALL OF THE
SECURITY THAT'S NEEDED AND ON
TOP OF THAT EVEN IF THEY DID.
THAT THERE'S A LOT OF INSIDERS
HAVE COMING THAT COMES AS A
RESULT. OF MANY PERPETRATORS OF
IDENTITY THEFT IN THE WORKPLACE
FOR EXAMPLE ARE PEOPLE WHO WORK
IN THAT WORK PLACE WHICH IS WHY
IT'S IMPORTANT TO CHECK THE
CREDENTIALS OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
WORKING. IN THOSE KINDS OF
PLACES YOU HAVE CONTROL OVER IT
SYSTEMS PAYROLL HR- AND THINGS
LIKE THAT- SO. THAT MAYBE THAT
HELPS A LITTLE BIT- MISTER CHAIR
UNDERSTAND THE FRAME OF THIS
DEBATE. THANK YOU MISS LASKO
STEVEN CUMMINS. I WOULD ONLY ADD
TO THAT BUT RANSOMWARE AND THE
SAND THESE THESE TYPES OF CYBER
THREATS HAVE BEEN INCREASING
PRIOR TO THE CONFLICT THAT WHERE
IT IS HAPPENING RIGHT NOW AND WE
HAVE NO REASON TO BELIEVE THAT
THIS IS MAGICALLY GOING TO
DECREASE WE WERE ON THE TREND.
TO CONTINUE TO SEE THE INCREASE
IN THE TARGET RIGHT NOW IS NOT
ACTUALLY A LARGE SWATHS OF
CONSUMER DATA IF THEY'RE THEY'RE
TARGETING BUSINESSES SMALL
BUSINESSES BUT IT'S REALLY TO
GET A REFRESH OF THAT DATA AT
THE STATIC DATA THAT IS
NECESSARY TO PERPETRATE A LOT OF
THESE CRIMES IT'S ALREADY OUT
THERE AND AS WE ADD NEW
MECHANISMS. TO DETECT THAT FRAUD
AND DETERMINED THAT FRAUD THEN
THOSE THREAT ACTORS NEED THAT
ADDITIONAL DATA I THINK THE BEST
EXAMPLE THAT I CAN GIVE IS AT
THAT DURING THE HEIGHT OF THE
UNEMPLOYMENT. IDENTITY THEFT
ISSUES BACK IN- LATE LAST EARLY
LAST YEAR LATE TWENTY TWENTY
WHEN THE STATE'S ADDED
ADDITIONAL VERIFICATION
PROCESSES THAT REQUIRE DRIVER'S
LICENSE INFORMATION WE SWEET
IMMEDIATELY SAW A SHIFT. WITH
THE THREAT ACTORS GOING AFTER
AUTO INSURANCE COMPANIES BECAUSE
WHO HAS THAT DRIVER'S LICENSE
INFORMATION READILY AVAILABLE
AND WHO MAY NOT HAVE. THE CYBER
SECURITY INFRASTRUCTURE TO KEEP
THOSE INTRUSIONS OUT WELL THEY
WENT AFTER AUTO INSURERS AND
ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND GEICO WHO
DID SUFFER A DATA BREACH EVEN
PUT ON THEIR NOTIFICATION
WARNING THE INDIVIDUALS WHO HAD
THEIR INFORMATION COMPROMISED
THAT THEY BELIEVED. THEIR
SYSTEMS WERE COMPROMISED AND
THAT DATA WAS TAKEN IN ORDER TO
COMMIT- UNEMPLOYMENT IDENTITY
THEFT AND FRAUD. SO AS WE NEED
TO KEEP IN MIND THAT AS WE ADD
THESE ADDITIONAL FRAMEWORKS THAT
THE THIEVES ARE A CRAFTY LOT WHO
ARE STAYING ON TOP OF THESE
THINGS THAT THEY WILL CONTINUE
TO TRY TO GET THE DATA THAT'S
NECESSARY TO THWART THOSE. AND
IF I MAY ONE MORE THING MISTER
CHAIR- THIS WILL ASK AS MAKES A
VERY IMPORTANT POINT AS WELL AND
AS DID MR GRANT JUST A FEW
MOMENTS AGO. THERE IS THIS
ONGOING PERPETUAL CAT AND MOUSE
GAME BETWEEN THE GOOD GUYS AND
THE BAD GUYS AND MISTER GRANT
MADE A COMMENT- THAT. A LOT OF
IDENTITY THEFT THAT WE'RE SEEING
NOW IS A RESULT OF THE FACT THAT
THE THIEVES HAVE CAUGHT UP TO
THE TECHNOLOGY BUT THERE'S THIS
CONSTANT EVOLUTION THAT AS SOON.
AS I GET ANY THIEVES FIGURE OUT
A WAY AROUND OVERTHREW
BUSINESSES HAVE TO BUILD UP THAT
WALL BETTER BIGGER DIFFERENTLY.
AND THEN THE THIEVES TRY TO FIND
A WAY IN OVER THROUGH AROUND AND
IT'S- AND IT'S A NEVER ENDING
CYCLE BUT IT DIED THAT'S JUST
REALLY THE NATURE OF THE OF THE
PROCESS THANK YOU IN THIS
DISCUSSION FITS NICELY IN MY
LAST QUESTION BEFORE I ASK THAT
I WANT I DID WANNA RECOGNIZE MS
AUSTIN WHO WAS OUR HAND RAISED.
**** ME ON MUTE. BECOMING ONION
IS AWESOME YOU MIGHT. I WAS. YES
YOU WERE JUST TOO QUICK FOR ME A
MISTER CHAIR. SO NOW JUST TWO
QUICK POINTS I THINK REALLY
TIGHT ENDS TOO- THE OTHER PANEL
MEMBERS AT COMMENTS WHICH RANG
SO TRUE TO ME. AS KIND OF AN
UNDERGROUND ON THE GROUND
INDIVIDUAL. AND WHEN YOU ASK THE
QUESTION- YOU KNOW AND TRY TO
NARROW DOWN. YOU KNOW HOW MANY
INDIVIDUALS. HAVE SUFFERED FROM
THIS TYPE OF VICTIM AND
VICTIMIZATION. I CAN TELL YOU
ONE THING AND THAT IS THAT. YOU
COULD GIVE ME. OR ANY INDIVIDUAL
THAT I WORK WITH. A VERY SMALL
AMOUNT OF YOUR PERSONAL
IDENTIFYING INFORMATION. AND
WITHIN AN HOUR I COULD HAVE
COLLECTED ENOUGH OF YOUR
PERSONAL IDENTIFYING
INFORMATION. THROUGH THE
INTERNET TO HAVE A FULL WHAT WE
CALL IN THE CRIMINALS. ARE
PRACTICED PROFILE ON YELP. AND
THAT IS THROUGH POSSIBLY
PURCHASING YOUR SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBER. ACTUALLY THE DARK LAB-
PUBLIC SEARCHES THAT I WOULD PAY
A SMALL. FEE TO BE ABLE TO GET
ALL OF YOUR YOU KNOW TITLE
DOCUMENTS. TITLED THAT IS JUST
CRAZY RAMPANT THESE DAYS- AND I
WOULD BE ABLE TO PUT TOGETHER A-
VERY. HEARTY PACKET. ON ANYBODY.
NOW SO. SO EVEN IF AN INDIVIDUAL
ISN'T QUITE. REGISTERED OR
RESPONDING. AS A VICTIM OF THESE
TYPES OF CRIMES OR BEING
CAPTURED BY THE DATA. I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE. THAT
BEHIND MY COMPUTER WITH A VERY
SMALL AMOUNT OF INFORMATION
PERHAPS JUST EVEN YOUR NAME. I
CAN HAVE AN ENTIRE PROFILE ON
YOU THAT WOULD ALLOW ME. TO
PERPETRATE. THESE TYPES OF
CRIMES. IN A VERY SHORT AMOUNT
OF TIME SO IT'S JUST KIND OF. A
WAY TO THINK ABOUT. OUR
VULNERABILITY INSTEAD OF JUST
KIND OF THE NUMBERS OF WHO'S
ACTUALLY. BEEN EXPOSED AND THEN
JUST ONE OTHER READ COMMENTS
ABOUT THE INNER. ISSUE INCURRED
. I OUR CITIZENRY OUR PERSONALLY
IDENTIFYING INFORMATION IS A
COMMODITY ON THE WORLD MARKET.
IT IS OUR GUY AS INDIVIDUALS A
PERSONAL IDENTIFYING INFORMATION
MY NAME. MY GENDER MY SOCIAL MY
DRIVER'S LICENSE WHERE I LIVE
WHERE I WENT TO SCHOOL ALL OF
THOSE THINGS MY MEDICAL RECORDS.
ZACH IS A MASSIVE COMMODITY. ON
THE GRAY MARKET. AND WHAT I MEAN
BY THAT IS RIGHT THIS VERY
MOMENT THIS INFORMATION IS BEING
PACKAGED AND RESOLD. AND DUMPS
SOMETIMES WHAT WE MIGHT CALL A
DATA DUMP OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT. AND SO THE VERY INSIDIOUS
NATURE OF THE- KIND OF
OMNIPRESENCE THEFT OF OUR
IDENTITIES BEING COMPROMISED AND
STOLEN. IS THAT THERE IS A HUGE
FINANCIAL MOTIVATION. OR
INDIVIDUAL ARE NOT ANY
INDIVIDUAL EXCUSE ME
INTERNATIONAL- ENTITIES. THAT
ARE OFTEN SUPPORTED BY THEIR
GOVERNMENT. TO COLLECT AND SELL
THIS DATA. AS A VERY- HIGH LEVEL
QUEMADA ON THE MARKET AND SO WE
HAVE GOVERNMENT ACTORS IN OTHER
COUNTRIES AND RUSSIA IS ONE THAT
WE KNOW. HAS SPECIALIZED IN THIS
PARTICULAR FORM OF- MANIPULATION
OF OTHER PEOPLE'S IDENTITY.
WHERE IN. COLLECTING THIS
INFORMATION RELATED TO THE
CITIZENRY AND IN PARTICULAR
CITIZENS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS FAIR GAME. CHINA'S
WE DON'T HAVE WE CAN'T
NECESSARILY REACH OUT AND TOUCH
THOSE ACTORS BUT WE CAN FOCUS ON
HOW TO ADDRESS THE CONDUCT ONCE
IT FALLS BACK HERE THANK YOU MS
AUSTIN PRITCHETT- AND WE WILL
JUST FOR THE RECORD GET TO YOU
AND TO MR GRANT IN JUST A MOMENT
WITH PANEL TOO I HAD ONE LAST
QUESTION FOR PANEL ONE AND THEN
I DO WANT TO OPEN UP MY
COLLEAGUES AND GOING BACK TO
WHAT YOU'RE DISCUSSING I THINK
YOU'D DISCUSSED HOW. THE HACKERS
WERE INVOLVING A LOT OF WAYS TO
TRY TO HIT WEAK POINTS IN AND
CATCH UP TO- AREAS IT WEAK
TARGETS- TRYING TO SORT OF
TARGET RICH ENVIRONMENTS- I WAS
WONDER IF YOU COULD BRIEFLY
SPEAK TO- ANY TREND YOU'D SEEN
IN RECENT YEARS OR MONTHS AS TO
THE TACTICS THEY'RE USING THE
TYPES OF IDENTITY THEFT THERE
TORY TARGETING. THE TYPES OF
ACTORS WITH THE SMALL BUSINESSES
INDIVIDUALS WHO WHO WHO ARE THEY
MOVING TO- JUST KIND OF GIVING
US A SENSE OF WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING. MR CHER. IF I MAY JUST
START ANSWERING THE QUESTION I
THINK THAT ONE OF THE BIGGER
WEAKNESSES THAT WE HAVE SEEN IT
AND- IDENTITY THEFT ARE
CONSUMERS THEMSELVES. THERE ARE
PLENTY OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
SUSCEPTIBLE TO USE SPEAR
PHISHING AND OTHER. ATTACKS
CLICK ON THIS CLICK ON THAT- I
AM LOOKING FOR TO RAISE FUNDS
FOR MY CHARITY- I AM AMAZON
TRYING TO VERIFY YOUR PURCHASE.
THINGS LIKE THAT. THERE'S AN
ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF CARE THAT
NEEDS TO BE TAKEN WHICH IS NOT
NECESSARILY DONE WITH A GREAT
DEAL OF EFFICIENCY ON THE PART
OF INDIVIDUALS. AND AS YOU KNOW
THE CHAIN. OF OF STRENGTH IS
ONLY AS WEAK AS ITS WEAKEST
LINK. AND UNFORTUNATELY A LOT OF
CONSUMERS THEMSELVES CAN BE
THEIR OWN WORST ENEMIES ARE
THEIR OWN WORST VICTIMS. THANK
YOU MR MCMAHON'S OFFICE. YES I
I'D LIKE TO COMMENT THAT WHILE
THERE IS SOME SOME TROOPS TO-
CONSUMERS BEING A PART OFTHIS
EQUATION- AND THERE IS A GREAT
DEAL OF SOCIAL ENGINEERING GOING
ON RIGHT NOW- THAT IS ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE'VE SEEN- IT RISE
SIGNIFICANTLY- HACKED INSTAGRAM
ACCOUNTS- GOOGLE VOICE
UNFORTUNATELY THE THREAT ACTORS
ARE ESSENTIALLY TALKING PEOPLE
INTO SHARING THEIR MULTI FACTOR
AUTHENTICATION CODES IT'S
THEY'RE GIVING THEM A REALLY
GOOD REASON AND THEY'RE MAKING
IT VERY VERY PERSONAL SO IF AN
INDIVIDUAL HAS A PROFILE WHERE
THERE'RE- VERY MUCH- A VERY
GIVING PERSON THEY VOLUNTEER
FOR- CAUSES AND THEIR PURPOSE
DRIVEN AND- THE- PERHAPS DONATE
TO CHARITIES. THAT WILL BE THE
HOOK I THEY'LL REACH OUT TO THEM
IN SOME WAY- I DON'T YOU WANT TO
HELP ME WITH MY CHARITY DONATE
TO THIS CHARITY AND HERE'S HOW
YOU CAN DO IT AND THEY END UP
THAT YOU TALKING THEM INTO
CONVINCING THEM TO SHARING- NOT
ONLY THEIR LOG IN CREDENTIALS
BUT THAT ALSO IF THEY HAVE MULTI
FACTOR AUTHENTICATION THOSE
THOSE MFA COATS. AND THAT FROM
OUR VIEW WHEN WE ARE TALKING TO
THESE VICTIMS THOSE ARE THE
SMALLER DOMESTIC- CRIMINALS THE
LARGE SCALE FRAUD RINGS AREN'T
IN IT REALLY ENGAGING AND THAT
LEVEL OF BEHAVIOR WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THOSE LARGER RANGE
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT AS THE
RANSOMWARE AND THE TARGET OF. UP
FOR THE RANSOMWARE THREAT ACTORS
IS REALLY- LARGER BUSINESSES YES
SOME SMALL TO MEDIUM SIZE
BUSINESSES BUT REALLY IT'S THE
LARGER BUSINESSES BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT ACTUALLY AFTER THAT
CONSUMER DATA THEY WANT ALL OF
THE BUSINESS INFORMATION AND
DATA THEIR THEIR INTELLECTUAL
PROPERTY WELL SOME OF THAT
CONSUMER DATA BE SWEPT UP IN
THAT NECK BUT IT'S NOT REALLY
THE TARGET SO WE. WE DO NEED TO
BE CAREFUL THAT WE SO. CONFLATE
THESE THESE ISSUES AND TRY TO-
SUMMARIZE AND TO THE POINT THAT
THEY WE'VE JUST WE HAVEN'T
DISTILLED THEM ENOUGH BECAUSE
REALLY THERE'S SO MUCH OF THIS
GOING ON WE NEED TO LOOK AT THAT
PARTICULAR THREAT ACTORS AND
WHAT THEIR MOTIVATIONS ARE WHAT
THEY'RE AFTER AND UNFORTUNATELY-
THE BARRED ENTRY IN THE FRAUD
ECOSYSTEM AS I'M SURE- MISS
AUSTIN CAN. I CAN ATTEST TO HAS
BEEN DRAMATICALLY LOWERED YOU
DON'T HAVE TO NECESSARILY HAVE
ANY SPECIAL SKILL SET TO BECOME.
A FRAUDSTER AND IT THERE'S A
VERY LARGE BREATH OF INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE COMMITTING THIS FRAUD
AND THEIR TARGETS ARE VARIED.
YEAH I AGREE WITH THAT AS WELL
MISTER CHAIRMAN ADDED AND- WE'VE
ALL SEEN THOSE EMAILS AND
THEY'RE REALLY GOOD AND THEY'RE
REALLY PERSUASIVE AND THEY'RE
REALLY COMPELLING AND EVEN THE
MOST TRAINED AND VERSED- IN NOT
CLICKING THINGS. CAN FALL PREY I
CLICKED ON ONE LINK- TOO MANY
AND CAUSE HAVOC HERE IN MY
OFFICE A FEW YEARS AGO SO IT
DOES HAPPEN AND EVEN AS GOOD AS
AND THOUGHTFUL AND CAREFUL AS
CONSUMERS ARE THERE'S STILL
PLENTY OF BAD GUYS OUT THERE
THAT ARE REALLY GOOD AT WHAT
THEY DO. WHICH IS WHY AS MR
GRANT SAID FOR EXAMPLE THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY HAS TO
PARTNER WITH GOVERNMENTS TO FIND
WAYS TO MAKE- TO KEEP THESE
INSTANCES OF IDENTITY THEFT AS
LOW AS POSSIBLE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR ALLMAN- IS ALASKA'S I
WANT TO OPEN UP TO MY COLLEAGUES
FOR QUESTIONS HERE FOR EITHER
THE PANELS- AND I WANT TO FIRST
ASK IF MY VICE CHAIR- BORDERS
HAS ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
CHAIR. OF THEM WANT TO THANK ALL
THE PANELISTS- FOR- APPEARING
TODAY. VERY INFORMATIVE VERY
HELPFUL- THIS MIGHT BE A
QUESTION TO POSE TO- MISTER
GRANT- OR ANYBODY ELSE FOR THAT
MATTER- DO YOU THINK THAT. FROM
A LEGISLATIVE STANDPOINT HE IT
WOULD BE WORTHWHILE- TO HAVE A
PIECE OF LEGISLATION THAT
MANDATED THE DISCLOSURE OF A
RANSOMWARE EVENT OR A BREACH OF
ANY KIND SO THAT INDIVIDUALS OR
BUSINESSES WOULD HAVE TO SUBMIT.
NOTICES FORMAL NOTICES TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT AS A MEANS FOR US TO
ACCUMULATE AS MUCH UP TO DATE
KNOWLEDGE AS WHAT'S OCCURRING AS
WELL AS DISCLOSED TO THOSE THAT
MIGHT HAVE BEEN IMPACTED. DO YOU
THINK SOME LIKE THAT WOULD BE
WORTHWHILE. WELL I'LL SAY
THEY'RE ALREADY GETTING PRETTY
MUCH EVERY STATE HAS A DATA
BREACH LAWN PLACE TODAY ALREADY
AND SO YOU HAVE REPORTING GOING
ON- YOU KNOW BASED OUT OF
WASHINGTON DC THERE'S BEEN
DISCUSSIONS AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
OVER WHETHER THINGS LIKE
RANSOMWARE ATTACKS IF. YOU KNOW
SOMEBODY'S. AN ORGANIZATION AS
PART OF CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
J. LIKE THE COLONIAL PIPELINE
THAT WE SAW. I GET ATTACKED
ABOUT A YEAR AGO WHETHER THAT
NEEDS TO BE REPORTED TO SOMEBODY
LIKE DEPARTMENT HOMELAND
SECURITY CYBERSECURITY AND
INFRASTRUCTURE SECURITY AGENCY.
BECAUSE IT HAS A CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE COMPONENT ON TOP
OF JUST DATA BEING STOLEN- BUT-
I WILL SAY A DATA BREACH
NOTIFICATION IS NOT AN AREA
WHERE I AM I AM. I HAVE DEEP
EXPERTISE BUT I'M PRETTY SURE
THAT CALIFORNIA OTHER STATES
ALREADY HAVE LAWS TODAY THAT ARE
ARE COVERING- THOSE SORTS OF
INCIDENCES SO WHAT DO WE HAVE A
RULE ON RANSOMWARE. WELL I WAS
GOING TO ASK IF WE MIGHT REFER
THAT QUESTION TO DEPUTY ATTORNEY
GENERAL LAWSON WHO MIGHT BE WELL
POSITIONED ANSWER. I'M WITH WE
I'M NOT AWARE OF ANYTHING ABOUT
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT NOTIFICATION
REGARDING RANSOMWARE SCENARIOS
WHICH I NOW HAVE BECOME YOU KNOW
OBVIOUSLY VERY SIGNIFICANT- WE
DO AND HAVE A LONG STANDING
REPORTING LIVE AS SIMILAR TO
WHAT MISTER GRANT MENTIONS THAT
MANY STATES ACTUALLY MODELED
AFTER THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND- AT MOST- AS FAR AS I AM
AWARE THAT MOST BUSINESS WITHIN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS WELL
AWARE OF IT AND TO COMPLY WITH
THOSE REPORTING- LIES IN TERMS
OF NOTIFYING. YOU FRY GOT NOTICE
CHECK NOTIFICATIONS YOURSELF WE
GET ON SO OFTEN THAT OFTEN TIMES
WE DON'T EVEN PAY ATTENTION WHEN
YOU GET A NEW CREDIT CARD IN THE
MAIL AND THEY TELL YOU TO THROW
OUT YOUR OLD ONE HI BUT I DON'T
BELIEVE WE HAVE ONE-
SPECIFICALLY RELATED TO
RANSOMWARE. THANK YOU AND I SEE
MISS ALASKA'S HAS HER HAND UP.
OF I CAN CONFIRM THAT WE DO NOT
HAVE A SPECIFIC LAW RELATED TO
RANSOMWARE WE DO HAVE IN
CALIFORNIA WE DO HAVE OUR DATA
BREACH NOTIFICATION LAW AND- I
THINK EVERYONE. LISTENING SHOULD
PAT THEMSELVES ON THE BACK
BECAUSE IT WAS CALIFORNIA THAT
STARTED THE TREND IN TWO
THOUSAND FOUR THEY PASSED THE-
MAYBE WAS TWO THOUSAND THREE
WHEN IT WAS PASSED BUT IT WENT
INTO EFFECT IN TWO THOUSAND FOUR
IN THE I. T. R. C. SUBSEQUENTLY
STARTED CAPTURING THIS REPORTED
DATA TWO THOUSAND FIVE. I WOULD
ENCOURAGE US TO THINK ABOUT THE
NOTIFICATION LAWS EVEN THOUGH
THEY EXIST IN ALL OF THE STATES.
I CAN'T SAY THAT OUR RESEARCH
HAS SHOWN US THAT MANY OF THE
NOTIFICATIONS. OUR I DON'T WANT
TO SAY LARGELY MEANING LESS BUT
THERE IS NOT ENOUGH TRANSPARENCY
IN THE NOTIFICATIONS TO MAKE
THEM MEANINGFUL ENOUGH TO THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE AFFECTED AND
JUST THINGS LIKE SPECIFICALLY
LISTING WHAT SPECIFIC DATA WAS
COMPROMISED- COULD ACTUALLY BE
VERY HELPFUL SO SOME OF THESE
NOTIFICATIONS THAT ARE SENT OUT
WILL SAY SOMETHING A BREACH HAS
OCCURRED BUT THEY GIVE. UP VERY
LITTLE GRANULAR DATA AND-
FINANCIAL INFORMATION WAS
COMPROMISED SO IT WE COULD ALSO
PERHAPS FOCUS ON- BEEFING UP AND
END UP MAKING THOSE THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR NOTIFICATION OF
MORE MEANINGFUL AND MORE
TRANSPARENT AND I THINK THAT
WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL FOR THE-
END THE VICTIMS THAT ARE
AFFECTED. THANK YOU ESPECIALLY
ON THE RANSOMWARE AKAM INTERIM I
DID HAVE A CONSTITUENT THAT-
WENT THROUGH A PROCESS LIKE
THIS. AND IT BECAME COST OF
DOING BUSINESS CALCULATION ON
WHETHER THEY JUST SIMPLY PAID-
BUT THEY DID NOTIFY THE FBI AND
GIVEN THE STRUCTURE VOLUME OF
HOW THESE ARE BEING CONDUCTED.
EVERY SINGLE DAY EVERY SINGLE
HOUR THERE'S SIMPLY- OVERWHELMED
AND IF YOU I THINK WE ALSO
ENCOUNTER- A DEGREE OF
DISCRETION THAT CERTAIN
BUSINESSES WANT TO BE DISCREET-
ABOUT THE DISCLOSURE OF WHAT
OCCURRED. AND THE FACT THAT THEY
PAID OUT AND I HAD HEARD
SOMEBODY MENTION WHETHER OR NOT.
THERE WOULD BE LEGISLATION
CONTEMPLATED. CORLEY'S POLICY
CONSIDERED TO BE CONTEMPLATED
THAT WOULD MAKE IT ILLEGAL TO
PAY A RANSOM- AND I KNOW THAT
GETS INTO A WHOLE. HORNET'S NEST
OF LEGAL ISSUES- DO YOU HAVE ANY
THOUGHTS ALL IN ALL CONCLUDE
HERE GIVE ANY THOUGHTS ON THE
UTILITY. OF SOMETHING LIKE THAT. I'M ASSUMING THAT IS THAT
DIRECTED TO ME YES IT IS- I
THINK THE DEVIL WOULD BE IN THE
DETAILS IN THAT IN THAT
SITUATION BECAUSE THERE COULD BE
A NUMBER OF UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES. AND SO WHILE
TRANSPARENCY WHEN INDIVIDUALS
ARE IMPACTED AND THEIR DATA IS
COMPROMISED IS- NOT AN ISSUE
THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT AND WE
NEED TO CONTINUE IN THAT
DIRECTION- YOU KNOW WHEN WE LOOK
AT THE RANSOMWARE. PROCESSES
THERE IT IT HAS BECOME A
CALCULATED BUSINESS DECISION
AND- THE I.TERROR SEASON
ORGANIZATION CURRENTLY HAS NOT
TAKEN AN OFFICIAL STANCE ON
WHETHER RETAIL. ADVISED
BUSINESSES TO EITHER PAY OR NOT
PAY THE RANSOM AT THIS POINT IT
IS AN INDIVIDUAL BUSINESS
DECISION. AND THUS FAR WHAT
WE'VE SEEN. IS THAT THE THREAT
ACTORS. IT'S OUR- HISTORICALLY
THEY HAVE BEEN HONORING THE CODE
AND SO WHEN THE RANSOM IS PAID
THEY ARE NOT RELEASING THE DATA
WE HAVE STARTED TO SEE A FEW OF
THE BAD ACTORS WHO ARE GOING
AHEAD EVEN WHEN THE RANSOM IS
PAID THEY'RE RELEASING THE DATA
SO. THE ENTIRE. BUSINESS MODEL
AND I USE THAT TERM LOOSELY. IT
COULD COLLAPSE AS AS THE THIEVES
ACT WITHOUT HONOR AND START
RELEASING THE DATA ANYWAY- BUT
WE DON'T WE DON'T HAVE AN
OFFICIAL POSITION ON THE UTILITY
OF. MAKING THAT. NOT PAYING A
RANSOM OUR REQUIRE- LET JUST A
REQUIREMENT OR LEGISLATING THAT. THANK YOU A CENTER BORDERS-
AND I KNOW THAT YOU'VE EXPRESSED
INTEREST IN THOSE SO SELECTED
LEGISLATION LIKE THIS IN THE
PAST AND- IT'S SOMETHING I KNOW. WE'VE TALKED ABOUT- WORKING ON
TOGETHER SO. AT THIS ISSUE IN
SOME OF THE PROS AND CONS. OF
CINDERELLA GIVEN QUESTIONS YEAH
I DIDN'T. KNOW WHO YOU ARE. I
THINK YOU HAVING A DIFFERENT
CONVERSATION IF YOU'RE SPEAKING
TO A PANEL IN CONGRESS- YOUR
STATE GOVERNMENT. WHAT DO YOU
AROUND THE COUNTRY. CAN YOU GIVE
ME. ANY VIEW- YOUR YOUR SENSE OF
BEST PRACTICES IS THERE IS THERE
A- OF SOME LAWS THAT ARE ON THE
BOOKS. WERE BEING CONSIDERED IN
OTHER STATES. THAT WE OUGHT TO
KNOW ABOUT AND CONSIDER AS WE'RE
TRYING TO THINK OF WAYS TO.
ADDRESS THE VERY REAL ISSUES AND
VERY FRIGHTENING ISSUES EVEN
RAISING TODAY AND IN TODAY'S
HEARING. I THINK ERIC MAYBE
TRYING TO TALK WITH THEM YET BUT
- WE ARE EXCELLENT. MY KIDS
ALWAYS SAY I SOUND BETTER ON
MUTE- A COUPLE OF A COUPLE OF
THOUGHTS- SENATOR THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION- THERE'S A NUMBER
OF. STATUTES AND RULES THAT I
MENTIONED AT THE BEGINNING OF MY
PRESENTATION THAT ARE IN PLACE
THAT I THINK ARE REALLY HELPFUL
FOR EXAMPLE- FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS HAVE TO HAVE A HAVE
TO COMPLY WITH THE KNOW YOUR
CUSTOMER REQUIREMENTS AND THAT
INCLUDES THINGS LIKE MATCHING ON
A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT THINGS%
LIKE A DRIVER'S LICENSE NUMBER
AND A SOCIAL AND DATE OF BIRTH
AND OTHERS. THERE'S REQUIREMENTS
THAT OUR MEMBERS THE CONSUMER
REPORTING AGENCIES REPORT
ADDRESS DISCREPANCIES TO USERS
OF CONSUMER REPORTS LIKE LENDERS
AND CREDITORS AND OTHERS AND
THERE'S A LONG LIST OF STATUTES
AND RULES THATARE IN PLACE BOTH
IN CALIFORNIA AND OF COURSE
NATIONALLY- AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL. AND I THINK ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE HAVE IS
MISTER GRANT HAD MENTIONED IS
THAT A LOT OF ARE A LOT OF THEIR
STRUCTURES STRUCTURES THAT WE'VE
BEEN LIVING UNDER OUR PAPER
BASED FOR AN ELECTRONIC WORLD
AND- MSTER GRANT MENTIONED SOME
THINGS THAT COULD BE DONE IN
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE PRIVATE
SECTOR AND PUBLIC SECTOR TO
HELP. BUT THAT WAS THAT SENATOR
ALAN THAT GIVES YOU JUST A FEW
HIGHLIGHTS OF SOME OF THE MANY
STATUTES AND RULES THAT ARE OUT
THERE TO ATTEMPT TO HELP PROTECT
CONSUMERS. AND I WOULD JUST SAY
ON MY SIDE I THINK PART OF IT'S
GOING TO. YEAH I'VE SEEN A LOT
OF YOU KNOW BILLS FOCUSING ON.
PUNISHMENTS IF A COMPANY IS
BREACHED. WHICH CAN BE HELPFUL
AS AN INCENTIVE TO PUT BETTER
CONTROLS IN PLACE BUT YOU KNOW
IN SOME CASES YOU'RE DEALING
WITH A VERY SOPHISTICATED NATION
STATE. WHO'S COMING AFTER A
SMALL COMPANY AND- YOU KNOW YOU
HAVE TO THINK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT. WHETHER THE STICK IS
ALWAYS THE BEST APPROACH OR
WHETHER THERE ARE OTHER THINGS
WE CAN DO TO. YOU KNOW GETTING
BACK TO THE POINT I RAISED
EARLIER IN MY OPENING STATEMENT.
HOW DO YOU GET AWAY FROM THESE.
OUTDATED SYSTEMS WHERE KNOWLEDGE
OF MY PERSONAL DATA. MEANS THAT
I'D MEET. IN YOU KNOW SOME YOU
KNOW ORGANIZATIONS- WAY TO
TURPIN WHO'S WHO. AND ACTUALLY
SHIFT TO SOMETHING THAT'S A
LITTLE BIT STRONGER STAYING
FOCUSED ON. POSSESSION OF
SOMETHING YEAH I MENTIONED YOU
KNOW I CAN I CAN WALK INTO A
BANK I CAN WALK INTO A
GOVERNMENT BUILDING- WITH MY
DRIVER'S LICENSE MY PASSPORT.
THAT MODEL THAT WORKS IN PERSON
WHERE THEY CAN LOOK AT SOMETHING
THAT I POSSESS IN HIS PHYSICAL
SECURITY FEATURES. HASN'T
TRANSLATED SO WELL ONLINE. AND
SO I'M YOU KNOW TO GO BACK TO
WHAT I SAID BEFORE I'M A REALLY
BIG PROPONENT OF WHAT STATES
COULD DO WITH DIGITAL
CREDENTIALS YOU KNOW THE
COUNTERPART TO THE DRIVER'S
LICENSE AND STATE ID CARDS. AS A
WAY TO GIVE PEOPLE SOMETHING
THEY CAN ACTUALLY USE TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES. AND THAT BUSINESSES
CAN USE TO PROTECT THEMSELVES.
AGAINST ALL OF THESE ATTACKS
THAT ARE YOU KNOW USING STOLEN
DATA. TO COMPROMISE IDENTITY.
THOSE ARE VERY SCALABLE TAX IN
FACT SOME OF THE TYPES OF
ATTACKS THAT YOU KNOW THE OTHER
YOU KNOW WITNESSES WERE TALKING
ABOUT EARLIER. ARE NOW GETTING
AUTOMATED BY BOTS WHERE YOU KNOW
YOU DON'T EVEN NEED TO HAVE
SOMEBODY NECESSARILY AT THE
OTHER END OF THE LINE TO TRICK
SOMEBODY INTO HANDING SOMETHING
OVER. YOU GET A EITHER DOES IT
THESE DAYS IT'S AUTOMATED- SO
YOU KNOW COREY FOR INNOVATION ON
THE ADVERSARY SIDE. SAYING THAT
SARCASTICALLY. BUT IT'S ACTUALLY
REALLY WORTH NOTING. HOW
SOPHISTICATED THE ATTACKERS HAVE
GOTTEN BECAUSE THESE ATTACKS ARE
SO LUCRATIVE AND THEY'RE ABLE TO
YOU KNOW THE ATTACKERS CAN JUST
SLICE THROUGH WHATEVER WE
CONTROLS WE HAVE. IN PLACE. AND
SO I THINK GETTING TO THING IT'S
LIKE. STRONGER DIGITAL
CREDENTIALS MOBILE DRY LICENSE A
SUMP THE STATE PRIVATE. MY KNEE
THAT WILL TAKE SOME TIME IN THE
NEAR TERM. I THINK WHAT YOU CAN
ACTUALLY DO LIKE I MENTIONED
BEFORE I USED TO RUN THE DIGITAL
IDENTITY GROUP. AT NEST. THIS
TEST DIGITAL IDENTITY GUIDELINES
THAT ARE- WIDELY USED NOT JUST
IN THE U. S. BUT ACROSS THE
GLOBE. THAT PRESCRIBE DIFFERENT
LEVELS OF WHAT PEOPLE CALL
IDENTITY PROOFING A DIFFERENT
ASSURANCE LEVELS. AND YOU KNOW
WHAT I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE
HAVE SETTLED ON IS THE MID LEVEL
TO HAVE WHAT'S KNOWN AS I. ALE
TO IDENTITY ASSURANCE LEVEL TWO.
THERE ARE SOLUTIONS THAT ARE OUT
THERE TODAY THAT ARE CERTIFIED
AS MEETING THOSE NEW SOLUTIONS.
YOU KNOW. I'LL SAY IT CAN BE. A
BIT OF A PAIN IN THE **** TO PUT
SOMEBODY THROUGH THEM BUT
ARGUABLY LESS SO THAN HAVING
YOUR CUSTOMER. AND BECOME A
VICTIM YOU KNOW DOWNSTREAM- BUT
LEVERAGING THOSE SOLUTIONS
CERTAINLY FOR. YOU KNOW
WEATHER'S SENSITIVE DATA OR A
LOT OF MONEY THAT IS AT STAKE
YOU KNOW THOSE KIND OF TOOLS
THAT ARE OUT THERE THAT TODAY
CAN START TO HELP AND THEN
LOOKED AT YOU KNOW MIGRATE TO
OTHER POSSESSION BASED TOOLS.
LIKE A MOBILE DRIVER'S LICENSE
IN THE FUTURE. IRAN YOU COMFORT
AND AID UNDERSTAND IT THE
COMMITTEE DOING SOME WORK IN
THAT YEAH I WAS I WAS GONNA ASK
YOU- AS AS JUST A FOLLOW UP TO
THAT MISTER GRAND I READ YOUR
TESTIMONY WITH GREAT INTEREST I
WOULD LISTEN TO A GREAT INTEREST
AND- YOU KNOW ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS I HAD BECAUSE- YEAH I
AS I MENTIONED I MYSELF HAVE
BEEN THE VICTIM OF IDENTITY
THEFT ON THREE SEPARATE
OCCASIONS AND I GET THOSE
NOTICES THAT MY SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBER ADDRESS AND MY KIDS ARE
ON THE DARK WEB OCCASIONALLY-
AND SO I THOUGHT YOUR PROPOSAL
FOR MOBILE DM DRIVER'S LICENSE
WAS WAS VERY INTERESTING THE
DIGITAL CREDENTIALING WAS VERY
INTERESTING. THE QUICK THING
THAT I DID NOT SEE A DRASTIC
TESTIMONIES IS- WHETHER WE WOULD
NEED THE CREDIT REPORTING
BUREAUS OR FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS TO ALSO ACCEPT THIS
SUMMER THAT REQUIRES SOME KIND
OF STATUTORY CHANGES WELL I JUST
BECAUSE SO MUCH OF THE ACTUAL
IDENTITY FRAUD TAKES PLACE IN
FINANCIAL FRAUD I AND I DIDN'T
SEE THAT CONNECTION BETWEEN LIKE
IT'S GREAT TO HAVE ANOTHER FORM
OF IDENTIFICATION BUT THE DID I
THINK THE MAIN DISCONNECT I HAVE
IS THAT THE I. D. THEFT THAT
WE'RE SEEING RIGHT NOW ANTI
FRAUD IS COMING FROM ACTUALLY-
PRIMARILY AMONG FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS. I THINK IT'S A
GOOD POINTS I'LL SAY A LOT OF
OUR MEMBERS ARE FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS AND CREDIT BUREAUS
ARE ALSO MEMBERS. THE LATTER
WEREN'T INVITED ME FIRST. THE
GROUP FIRST FORMED JOB. PART
BECAUSE SOME OF THEM. WHAT IS
IT. SOME OF THE BANKS WANT TO
GET BEYOND KNOWLEDGE BASE TOOLS
THAT THEY WERE OFFERING- BUT
AFTER WE PUBLISHED OUR BLUEPRINT
A COUPLE YEARS AGO THEY ALL CAME
TO US AND SO WE ACTUALLY THINK
ON BALANCE THIS IS. WHAT WE NEED
TO GO IN SO IT'S BEEN A GREAT
COALITION ARE REGARDING THE WE
HAVE A LOT OF DIFFERENT
INDUSTRIES ALL SUPPORTING THIS
POLICY BLUEPRINT- SO THE SHORT
ANSWER THAT WAS DO YOU NEED NEW
LAWS IF YOU HAVE DIGITAL
CREDENTIALS TO ENABLE TO BE
ACCEPTED. YOU DON'T- THE
DRIVER'S LICENSE IS ALREADY. YOU
KNOW. TRICKIER TO FACTO YOU KNOW
NATIONAL ID TODAY FOR MOST
PEOPLE. IN CONGRESS ACTUALLY
YEAR AND A HALF AGO PASSED
SOMETHING CALLED REAL ID
MODERNIZATION ACT WHICH UPDATED.
THE STATUTE FROM TWO THOUSAND
FIVE THAT CREATED THE FEDERAL
STANDARDS FOR THE REAL ID
DRIVER'S LICENSES. TO SAY THAT
IT DOES NOT HAVE TO JUST BE A
PLASTIC CARD IT COULD ALSO BE A
DIGITAL CREDENTIALS- AND BY THE
WEIGHT THAT WAS ONLY REALLY
NEEDED FOR THE TSA. OR OTHER
PARTS OF HOMELAND SECURITY TO BE
ABLE TO RECOGNIZE- DIGITAL
CREDENTIAL IN LITTLE PLASTIC- A
CARD. BUT IN THE FINANCIAL
SERVICES SECTOR WITH THE CREDIT
BUREAUS ARE PRETTY MUCH ANY
INDUSTRY. YOU KNOW TODAY THEY'RE
BASICALLY REQUIRED TO DO RISK
BASED ASSESSMENTS TO PROVE THAT
YOU REALLY ARE WHO YOU SAY YOU
ARE YOU KNOW IN BANKING
INSTRUMENT PEOPLE TEND TO CALL
THE KYC PROCESS KNOW YOUR
CUSTOMER- AND SO. THEY'RE BEING
YOU KNOW IN THE DIGITAL WORLD A
MIX OF PRODUCTS TODAY- THAT.
SOME OF THEM ARE QUITE GOOD SOME
OF THEM ARE ONCE ATTACKERS HAVE
CAUGHT UP WITH- I DON'T WANT TO
SEE THE GOVERNMENT THE ONLY
SOLUTION IS A LOT OF GREAT
INNOVATION HAPPENING. IN THE
SPACE A LOT OF IT BEING DRIVEN
BY COMPANIES IN CALIFORNIA- TO
STAY AHEAD OF THE ATTACKERS. BUT. AT THE END OF THE DAY GETTING
TO THAT. HOW WOULD I SAY IT. A
LOT OF INDUSTRIES. TO GET. FOR
LACK OF A BETTER TERM BUT ONLY
THE GOVERNMENT REALLY KNOWS THE
GOVERNMENT IS THE ONLY
NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED
AUTHORITATIVE ASHORE BY KENNEDY
AND SO YOU KNOW BEING ABLE TO
CLOSE THAT GAP BETWEEN THE
PHYSICAL AND DIGITAL CREDENTIALS
I THINK IS HOW WE START TO BRING
WORK DETERMINATIVE FACTORS INTO
THINGS INSTEAD OF THESE
PREDICTIVE FACTORS- BUT NO
INDUSTRY WOULD NOT NEED. AS FAR
AS I KNOW ANY ADDITIONAL LAWS OR
STATUTES TO BE PASSED
REGULATIONS IN ORDER TO START
ACCEPTING DIGITAL CREDENTIALS
THAT WERE BACKED BY BY
GOVERNMENTS THEY WOULD NEED TO
CHANGE IN PRACTICES THOUGH IS
THAT CORRECT. THEY WOULD HAVE TO
BE AT THAT DECIDE TO ADOPT YEAH
AND IN THIS CASE- WE'VE GOT- HOW
WOULD I SAY IT. THEY'RE ALL
EAGER TO DO THAT THESE DAYS I
THINK THIS IS VERY MUCH A MATTER
OF IF YOU LOOK INTO SOME OF OUR
MEMBERS ARE THEY'RE SAYING IF
YOU BUILD THIS WE WILL COME UP
YEAH- YOU KNOW THE COALITION
AGAIN IT WAS YOU KNOW FORMED OUT
OF THE- THE WAKE OF THE EQUIFAX
BREACH WHEN A LOT OF COMPANIES.
WERE SAYING WHAT WE'RE GETTING
TODAY IN TERMS OF KNOWLEDGE
BASED SOLUTIONS FROM VENDORS WE
NEED TO GET TO SOMETHING BETTER
YEAH AND THAT'S ACTUALLY WHY
THEY'VE ALL COME TOGETHER TO YOU
KNOW INVESTED IN. DENTAL FIRST
TRADING IN AND YOU KNOW
SUPPORTING THIS COALITION
ADVOCATING FOR THE POLICIES IS
THEY ARE VERY EAGER TO START
USING THESE TOOLS- BUT I'LL JUST
SAY AS AN EXAMPLE AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL WE'VE WORKED IN IN FACT MR
ALLMAN I'VE HAD BOTH BEEN
WORKING ON THIS AND TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. CONGRESS REQUIRED THE
SOCIAL SECURITY ADMINISTRATION
TO CREATE A NEW SYSTEM- THE
ACRONYMS TERRIBLE ALONG LIKE A
LOT OF GOVERNMENT ACRONYMS ECB
SPD ELECTRONIC CONSENT BASED
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER
VERIFICATION SYSTEM IT WAS
SOMETHING THAT THE FINANCIAL
SERVICES INDUSTRY WENT- TO
CONGRESS AND PUSH FOR- TO TRYING
TO DRESS WHAT HAS BEEN THE
FASTEST GROWING TYPE OF IDENTITY
FRAUD ACCORDING TO THE FEDERAL
RESERVE WHICH IS SYNTHETIC
IDENTITY FRAUD. WHERE IT'S NOT
THAT I'M STEALING ERIC'S
INFORMATION OR EVEN AS
INFORMATION AND YOU KNOW POSING
AS THEM IT SAID I'M CREATING
ESSENTIALLY A DIGITAL
FRANKENSTEIN WHERE I MIGHT TAKE.
MY NAME AND ERIC'S KIDS SSN YOU
KNOW THE BUREAU'S MIGHT NOT HAVE
SEEN AND SENDING OUT WITH A FAKE
BIRTHDAY AND APPLYING FOR CREDIT
AND ESSENTIALLY TRICKING YOU
KNOW THE BANKS AND THE COMPANIES
THAT THEY WORK WITH INTO
THINKING THAT THIS IS A REAL
PERSON IN ISSUING CREDITS YOU
KNOW THE FEDERAL RESERVE PUT OUT
A REPORT ABOUT A MONTH AGO THEY
SAID THIS IS NOW COSTING ABOUT
TWENTY BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR.
IN LOSSES IN THE BANKING SYSTEM.
ALL BECAUSE- IF I'M APPLYING TO
A BANK. ONLINE AND I SAY I'M
JEREMY GRANT WITH THE PARTICULAR
DATE OF BIRTH AND SSN. THERE'S
NEVER BEEN A WAY FOR THAT BANK
OR THEIR BUSINESS PARTNERS AND
END ANY VERIFICATION SIDE TO ASK
THE SSA. IS THERE REALLY THAT
PERSON WHO'S NOT THAT. AND SO
THE INABILITY TO SIMPLY GET A
YES NO ANSWER ME NOBODY'S ASKING
NECESSARY TO START SHARING
PERSONAL INFORMATION THAT'S GOT
A LOT OF SECURITY AND PRIVACY
ISSUES. JUST HOURS EIGHTY YES NO
THERE REALLY IS A JEREMY TO
GRANT WITH MY DATE OF BIRTH AND
SSN WHO'S NOT DEAD. IS AN
ESSENTIAL TOOL TO YOU KNOW WEED
OUT THE SYNTHETIC IDENTITY FRAUD
AND SO THIS IS AN AREA WHERE THE
BANK'S ADVOCATED FOR IT AND NOW
THEY'RE ALL INVESTING TO BUILD
IT BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO PAY FOR
IT ACTUALLY HAS TO SAY IS
REQUIRED TO. COLLECT FEES AND I
THINK THEY'RE AVERAGING ABOUT A
MILLION TRANSACTIONS A WEEK NOW
THROUGH THAT AS THE SYSTEM COMES
ON A PILOT HOPEFULLY TO RAMP UP
TO. YOU KNOW TEN OR TWENTY TIMES
THAT OVER THE NEXT YEAR. SO
INDUSTRIES VERY HUNGRY FOR THIS
AND WILLING TO ADAPT- AND CHANGE
THEIR WAYS THANKS FOR THE I. I
WOULD AGREE IF I IF I MAY MISTER
CHAIR- JUST TO PIGGYBACK ON WHAT
MR GRANT SAID THAT THE FINANCIAL
INCENTIVE FOR THE BET FOR THE
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS AND
CREDIT BUREAUS IS SIGNIFICANT
BECAUSE OFTENTIMES. THE
FINANCIAL REASONS IN THE CREDIT
BUREAUS THAT HAVE TO COVER THE
LOSSES. AND IT'S IN IT'S IN THE
BEST INTERESTS OF ALL YOUR
QUESTION MISTER CHAIR IS IF YOU
BUILD IT WILL THEY COME AND I
AND MISTER GRANT I THINK HAS
LAID OUT A VERY GOOD CASE AS TO
WHY THE ANSWER TO THAT QUESTION.
IS YES AND- AMONGST ONE AMONGST
THE OTHER THINGS THAT WE HAVE
ACCESS TO IN ADDITION TO THE ECB. S. V. READ MUNCH. WE ALSO HAVE
ACCESS EXAMPLE THE DEATH MASTER
FILE. WHICH IS JUST AS A STAPLE
. OF SERVICE THAT. TELLS US ALL
OF THE DECEASED ON ACROSS THE
COUNTRY WHO HAVE APPLIED FOR.
SEEKING BENEFITS THAT ALLOWS US
TO- BANK CREDIT FROM BEING
ISSUED IN A DECEDENT'S NAME
OFFER IDENTITY THEFT PURPOSES.
WHILE THERE IS SUCH A THING AS A
DEATH MASTER FILE THERE'S NO
SUCH THING AS A BIRTH MASTER
FILE SO WE DON'T NECESSARILY
HAVE ACCESS. TO NEW SSNS ARE
BEING ISSUED I THINK THE ECB S.
V. IS A GOOD START TO GET US ON
THAT ROAD BUT THERE WERE ALWAYS
LOOKING FOR NEW TOOLS AND NEW
TECHNOLOGIES TO TRY AS BEST AS
WE CAN. KEEP THE INCIDENTS OF
FRAUD AS LOW AS POSSIBLE AND I
WOULD JUST THE TRUTH WANT TO
CLARIFY I THINK MR GRANT'S.
RESPONSE TO THAT JUST I THOUGHT
THE PART IN YOUR TESTIMONY WHERE
YOU TALKED ABOUT THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN IT AND NOT IDENTIFIER
AND AUTHENTICATOR WAS WAS.
INTERESTING AND IT'S SOMETHING
THAT MATCHES WITH WITH OTHER
WHAT OTHER FOLKS THAT I'VE
TALKED TO SAID. WHICH IS THAT
THE SS AND IS VERY USEFUL AS AN
IDENTIFIER- THAT IS IT IS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE WHOLE BODY
OF INFORMATION ABOUT US. IT IS
PROBABLY NECESSARY FOR THAT
PURPOSE BUT THE IDEA THAT WE
SHOULD HAVE A SECRET ASSETS AND
WHEN THE ASSET MOST OF OUR SSNS
ARE ALREADY OUT THERE ON THE
DARK WEB. MAKES LESS AND LESS
SENSE OVER TIME AND SO THE IDEA
THAT IT COULD BE USED IN A AS AN
AUTHENTICATOR THAT IS TO SAY
PROOF OF WHO I AM. RATHER THAN
JUST AN IDENTIFIER THERE IS
SOMEBODY NICKNAMED DAVE MEN WITH
MY DATE OF BIRTH AND- THE
FOLLOWING ATTRIBUTES- IT MAKES
NO SENSE NO E. SETTLE ON THE
MOBILE DRIVER'S LICENSE. NOT ONE
OF THE IDEAS THAT I WAS PITCHED
TO ME BY SOME OTHER GROUPS WAS
THE ACCESS AND PLUS- AND I TAKE
FROM YOUR TESTIMONY THAT PART OF
THE REASON THE MAIN REASON THAT
YOU THINK THAT THAT'S REDUNDANT
AND UNNECESSARY. IS THAT THE
MOBILE DRIVER'S LICENSE WOULD
ALREADY COP WITH THAT PURPOSE AT
A FAR SMALLER FRACTION THE
CLASSES IS THAT A CORRECT
SUMMARY. THAT'S MY TAKE ON THE-
GET UP TO GET TO A POINT YOU
KNOW MR ALLMAN BEFORE TALKED
ABOUT THE OLD DOG ON THE
INTERNET CARTOON YEAH- IT'S
WORTH NOTING THAT CARTOON IS
GOING TO. TURN TWENTY NINE YEARS
OLD THIS JULY. WE MEANS. THOSE
DOGS ARE A- NOT WITH US ANYMORE
BECAUSE DOG YEARS IN THEIR KIDS
PROBABLY HAVE PASSED ON AS WELL.
THIS IS BEEN A REALLY HARD
PROBLEM TO SOLVE. AND THERE
THERE'S A REASON WE'RE STILL
STRUGGLING WITH IT IT'S NOT THAT
. YOU KNOW THIS YEAR HASN'T BEEN
GETTING ATTENTION ALL THIS TIME
YEAH BUT NO I THINK THE IDEA OF.
THERE ARE A LOT OF QUESTIONS IN
THE WAKE OF THE EQUIFAX BREACH
YOU NEED TO REPLACE THE SSN OR
DO SOMETHING ON THE BLOCKCHAIN
WITH THAT THAT. HONESTLY ALL
THOSE PICTURES KIND OF
CONFOUNDED ME IN TERMS OF I
WASN'T CLEAR HOW THAT WOULD
HELP. YOU KNOW MY TAKE WAS JUST
ACCEPT THAT IT'S AN IDENTIFIER
AND IT SHOULD NEVER BE AN
AUTHENTICATOR AND IF WE TRY TO.
MAKE THE S. ASCEND INTO
SOMETHING THAT IT'S NOT- I JUST
DON'T THINK WE'RE GOING TO GET
THAT FAR ALTHOUGH WE COULD
CERTAINLY SPEND BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN CONFUSE A LOT OF
PEOPLE. NONE OF THEM. I MEAN IF
I COULD JUST- I GUESS ONE
QUESTION I HAD ABOUT YOUR MOBILE
DRIVER'S LICENSE AND SOMEONE WHO
SUFFERED A BREACH. IF THE MOBILE
DRIVER'S LICENSE IS MEANT TO BE
AN AUTHENTICATOR WHICH I TAKE IT
IS- WHAT HAPPENS IF THAT GETS
BREACHED AND SO ONE OF THE
THINGS I LIKED ABOUT THE SS AND-
PLUS. IS THAT YOU COULD CHANGE
IT AT THE WAY IT WAS EXPLAINED
TO ME IF YOU COULD HAVE AN SS
AND ATTACHED TO LIKE A FOUR
DIGIT. ALPHANUMERIC CODE JUST TO
GIVE YOU ONE EXAMPLE ONE
ITERATION OF NSS AND
ALTERNATIVE- ED AND SO WHO'S
EVER BREACHED ALL YOU HAVE TO DO
IS CHANGE THE HELP OF. THEM THAT
YOU KNOW YOU SHOW YOUR
IDENTIFICATION. YOU ARE THEY
PROCREATE AND SEEN YOU COULD
CHANGE THAT NUMBER. INTO
SOMETHING ELSE I NOW PROTECT
PROTECTS AGAINST A LIKELY
INCIDENTS OF FUTURE HACKING IN
FUTURE THEFT- SO DOES YOUR
MOBILE DRIVER'S LICENSE PROPOSAL
HAVE SOME MUTABILITY.
ADAPTABILITY BUILT INTO IT AS
WELL. LOOK AT FIRST OFF I DON'T
WANT TO SUGGEST. IN FACT BRUCE
BECAUSE THE ONE THING YOU CAN BE
GUARANTEED IF YOU SAY SOMETHING
CAN'T BE ACTIVE WILL BE THEN
YOU'LL LOOK SILLY- I THINK.
THERE IS SECURITY YOU KNOW. TO
BE CLEAR IT'S NOT JUST A
PROPOSAL YOU KNOW THERE ARE
STANDARDS THAT ARE OUT THERE
THERE ARE COMPANIES LIKE APPLE
WORKING. TO ACTUALLY EMBED THIS
IN THE WALLET- YOU KNOW
SMARTPHONES- THE TSA SAID
THEY'RE GONNA START ACCEPTING
THEM SOME OF YOUR NEIGHBORING
STATES LIKE. UTAH AND ARIZONA.
HAVE STARTED TO ROLL THEM OUT-
SO IT IS YOU KNOW I DON'T KNOW.
CALIFORNIA MAY HAVE SOME EFFORTS
UNDERWAY I'M JUST NOT FAMILIAR
WITH THEM- BUT IT IS. YOU KNOW
BACKED BY. YOU KNOW. PRETTY
STRONG STANDARDS AND- IN AND
HACKABLE BUT THERE'S CERTAINLY A
LOT OF SECURITY WITH THAT I MEAN
MORE THAN ANYTHING ELSE WE HAVE
TODAY- I TAKE IT YOU KNOW IT'S-
THE DRUG ISSUE. HOW DO I SAY
THIS IF YOU PUT MORE SECURITY
FOCUSED ON THAT. THEN YOU'LL SEE
MORE ATTACKERS COME AFTER IT. I
THINK THAT'S ALWAYS TRUE IS WE
INNOVATE AND SECURITY AND THEN
THE ATTACKERS TRY TO CATCH UP
WITH US WE HAVE TO INNOVATE
AGAIN BUT I GUESS THE QUESTION
IS LIKE. THE MOBILE DRIVER'S
LICENSE NUMBER COULD BE CHANGED
OR COULD NOT BE CHANGED ON YOUR
PROPOSAL. I THINK THE NUMBER IS
ACTUALLY IRRELEVANT IN SOME
CASES AND THAT THE DRIVER'S
LICENSE NUMBER IS JUST AN
IDENTIFIER JUST LIKE THE SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBER. SHOW SSA WILL
LET YOU CHANGE YOUR SSN TODAY.
IF YOU CAN SHOW THAT IT'S BEEN
BREACHED AND YOU KNOW THINGS ARE
YOU HAVE TO HIT A CERTAIN
THRESHOLD- THERE ARE WAYS YOU
CAN CHANGE IT WITH THE S. TO
STAY I DON'T KNOW HOW TO DM VIS
HANDLE IT. I DON'T SEE ANY
REASON WHY YOU COULD NOT CHANGE
YOUR DRIVER'S LICENSE IDENTIFIER
NUMBER. BUT WHAT. DIVISION I'M
REALLY LAYING OUT IS HOW DO WE
GET AWAY FROM WE'RE KNOWING THAT
NUMBER ACTUALLY MEANS ANYTHING.
IT JUST BECOMES A MEANINGLESS
NUMBER THAT'S ONLY GOOD FOR
HELPING UNDERSTAND. YOU KNOW
WHICH GERMANY GRANTED ME AND
WHICH IS SOMEBODY WHO LIVES YOU
KNOW IN SACRAMENTO OR LA. WHO
HAPPENS TO YOU KNOW HAVE MY NAME
ALL UP THAT'S REALLY THE ONLY
THING THESE NUMBERS ARE GOOD FOR
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE. IT'S
SOMETHING I THINK IT'S AN
INTERESTING PROPOSAL SOMETHING
ON MY STAFF AND I WOULD LIKE TO
TALK TO YOU MORE ABOUT IN AND
GET A BETTER HANDLE ON SORT OF.
THE SCOPE AND VISION YOU HAVE A-
IT'S CERTAINLY A THOUGHTFUL
PROPOSAL- I HAVE DISLIKED TWO
MORE QUESTIONS ERE REAL
QUICKLY- AND THE FIRST IS GOING
BACK TO FINANCIAL FRAUD WHICH I
THINK IS PROBABLY. THE MAIN AREA
OF MY FOCUS- WHAT DO. THINK I.
THIS COULD BE. I IT AND- IS. OR
GRANT. REALLY ANY THAT- OF MULTI
. AUTHENTICATION OTHER IDEA
THAT'S BEEN PRESENTED TO. ME AND
MY STAFF- THERE ANYTIME SOMEONE
WANTS TO OPEN AN ACCOUNT. AND
ANY KIND OF CREDIT OR OTHERWISE
FINANCIAL. ACCOUNT IN MY NAME
AND IDENTITY THAT THAT WE HAVE
MULTI FACTOR AUTHENTICATION THE
SAME WAY WE DO WHEN I WANT TO
OPEN A GOOGLE MAIL ACCOUNT- IS
THAT SOMETHING THAT WE SEE IS
MEANINGFULLY. DETERRENT TO.
IDENTITY FRAUD IS THAT SOMETHING
THAT COMES WITH DRAWBACKS- ANY
COMMENTARY HERE WOULD BE
APPRECIATED- IS AUSTIN. SIR I
WELL WE WERE DISCUSSING THIS
PARTICULAR SUBJECT. ALL I COULD
THINK OF WAS BIOMETRICS AND DO A
LOT THAT OCCASION- WHICH I USE
ALL EVERY DAY IN OUT MULTIPLE
WAYS TO- ENTER THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE DATABASE. I TOOK OVER MY
CELL PHONE THINGS OF THAT
NATURE. AND AT THIS TIME USING A
TOOL LIKE THAT I THANK CATION OR
BIOMETRICS. ARE STILL RELATIVELY
SAFE. I JUST UNDERSTAND THAT MAY
BE A BRIDGE TOO FAR WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT YOU KNOW PERHAPS
THE AVERAGE INTO INDIVIDUALS.
EVERY DAY- ABILITY TO CONDUCT
COMMERCE IN A SECURE WAY. SO THE
TICKET IS SIMPLY YES I DO THINK
THOSE ARE VERY IMPORTANT YES I
DO THINK THAT THAT IS PART OF
THE WAVE OF THE FUTURE- MUCH
LIKE WE ALL PREDICTED. THAT TEN
YEARS FROM NOW WE WOULD BE
ADAPTING TO REMOTE WORK A CRISIS
PUSHED US TO LEARN HOW TO ADAPT
WITH THAT VERY QUICKLY. I THE
ONLY PRESENCE OF IDENTITY THEFT
IS IN A CRIMINAL PERSPECTIVE. IS
A CRISIS. AND WE'VE SEEN SO MUCH
OF IT THAT UNFORTUNATELY I FEEL
THAT- I IT'S NOT TAKEN AS
SERIOUSLY AS PERHAPS IT SHOULD.
BUT I HOPE I ANSWERED THAT
QUESTION I DO THINK IT IS THE
FUTURE UNLIKE SIDE PERHAPS
MISTER GRANT- AND THE OTHER
PANELISTS. I'M VERY FOCUSED ON.
ARE THERE ENOUGH- SOPHISTICATED
DETECTIVES ON THE STREET THAT I
CAN JUST ACTUALLY. FILE IS SIXTY
MILLION DOLLAR IDENTITY THEFT
FRAUD CASE SO THAT'S WHERE MY
DAY TO DAY AND THE FOCUS OF THE
GENERAL YOU KNOW INSURING THAT
WE HAVE VERY HIGHLY TRAINED
SOPHISTICATED LAW ENFORCEMENT.
IS WHERE MY DAY TO DAY. BUT
ANECDOTALLY AS SOMEONE WHO'S
BEEN DOING THIS FOR TWENTY
YEARS. I DO SEE THE CRISIS
PUSHING US TO BIOMETRICS. AND
AUTHENTICATION BUT I REALLY
THINK I HAVE MISTER GRANT MISS
ALASKA'S AT MR ALLMAN. THEY
ACTUALLY ARE WORKING IN THAT
KIND OF POLICY LEVEL OF WHAT IS
PRACTICAL. I DON'T I HOPE THAT
HELPS SOME MISTER CHAIRMAN IT
DOES VERY MUCH THANK YOU MY SON
IS ABOUT HIS HEAD OR HAND UP IN
AS AS MISTER. GRANT SO LET'S
START WITH MISS ALASKA'S. I
GUESS I WANT ADD THE- WE HAVE
THE I. TERZI IS ENCOURAGED
EVERYONE TO SIGN UP FOR MULTI
FACTOR AUTHENTICATION ON ALL OF
THEIR ACCOUNTS WHEREVER IT'S
AVAILABLE. AND WE WOULD LIKE TO
SEE THE PUBLIC ADOPTING IT EVEN
MORE WIDELY THAN THEY ALREADY
ARE THAT BEING SAID TO MAKE IT
MANDATORY WE HAVE TO CONSIDER
THAT THAT IS GOING TO CREATE
ACCESSIBILITY ISSUES FOR A
SEGMENT OF THE POPULATION. AND
SO BEFORE YOU COULD MAKE
SOMETHING LIKE THIS MANDATORY
THAT NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED AHEAD
OF TIME- YOU KNOW IN MY PERFECT
WORLD YES. MFA WOULD BE
MANDATORY WITH IT ALL JUST HAVE
TO USE IT BECAUSE IT IT HAS. SO
<c.magenta>ANY GREAT BENEFITS BUT THERE</c>
ARE CERTAIN PEOPLE THAT SIMPLY
DON'T ENGAGE DIGITALLY IN IN
THAT MANNER THEY DON'T KNOW HOW
TO HOW TO THEY WOULDN'T KNOW HOW
TO USE IT AND ADDITIONALLY WE'VE
HAD TREMENDOUS PROBLEMS WITH
PEOPLE TRULY EVEN THE ONES THAT
HAVE OPTED IN. TRULY NOT
UNDERSTANDING THAT THEY CANNOT
SURE THAT COAT HOW VITAL IT IS
THAT THEY DON'T SHARE THAT CODE
AND THEY ARE LOSING ACCESS TO
THEIR ACCOUNTS WE HAVE THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE THAT WE'VE TALKED TO
IN THE LAST YEAR ALONE. I THINK
I JUST LOOKED AT THE STATS IT
WAS. TOUGH FORTY ONE HUNDRED.
ADJUSTED FOR GOOGLE VOICE AND I
THINK WE HAVE ANOTHER COUPLE
THOUSAND FOR INSTAGRAM SO IT'S
PRIMARILY ON SOCIAL MEDIA. BUT
IT. WE WOULD HAVE BEFORE WE
START MAKING SOMETHING TRULY
COMPULSORY WE HAVE WE HAVE TO
HAVE SOME OF THOSE OTHER PARTS
ADDRESSED THE EDUCATIONAL
COMPONENT AS WELL AS THE- IN
ACCESSIBILITY AND THE BARRIERS
TO ACCESS THAT IT WOULD CREATE
FOR A CERTAIN SEGMENT OF THE
POPULATION. THANK YOU MISS
ALASKA'S MISTER GRANT. YES I
I'VE BEEN WORKING AROUND THE MFA
SPACED A REALLY LONG TIME- A LOT
OF MY FOCUS WHEN I WAS AT AND
THIS WAS PROMOTING THE ADOPTION
OF MULTI FACTOR AUTHENTICATION
AND TRYING TO COME UP WITH
BETTER STANDARDS THAT COULD MAKE
IT EASIER TO DEPLOY. AND T. TO
MISS CLASS BECAUSE IT'S ONE I
THINK THIS IS BUT ONE OF THE
PROBLEMS HAS BEEN- A LOT OF THE
FIRST GENERATION. MULTI FACTOR
AUTHENTICATION WE'VE SEEN HAS
BEEN DEVELOPED BY. I THINK WHAT
I AFFECTIONATELY CALL SECURITY-WE NEED BECAUSE I AM ONE- BUT
IT'S BEEN FOCUSED ON THE WAY
THAT WOULD ADD SECURITY IN A WAY
THAT MIGHT ACTUALLY DETRACT FROM
USER EXPERIENCE. SO EVERYBODY
HATES PASSWORDS ARE REALLY
REALLY HAS PASSWORD ON MOBILE
DEVICES. BUT WHEN WE'RE TELLING
YOU WHILE YOUR NEW
AUTHENTICATION CEREMONY IS
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE A PASSWORD
AND THEN WE'RE GONNA TEXT YOU A
CODE YOU'RE GOING TO FISH OUT A
TOKEN AND ENTER A SECOND
PASSWORD. NOBODY'S REALLY INTO
THAT- AND SO WHILE TURNING ON
MFA IS PROBABLY THE BEST PIECE
OF ADVICE I CAN GIVE TO ANYBODY
WHO'S WATCHING THIS HEARING OR
ANYBODY IN THE WORLD. IN TERMS
OF HOW TO PROTECT THEMSELVES.
THE INDUSTRY IS JUST NOW
STARTING TO DO SOME WORK AND HOW
DO YOU ACTUALLY YOU KNOW MAKE
MFA SOMEHING THAT IS JUST BUILT
IN RATHER THAN BOLTED ON- AND
THERE I'M ACTUALLY REALLY
BULLISH AND I THINK WE'RE ON THE
CUSP OF. NOW WE'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT THIS FOR YEARS AND IT'S
BECOME A LITTLE CLICHE BUT I
THINK WE'RE ACTUALLY GETTING
CLOSE TO KILLING THE PASSWORD OR
AT LEAST BEING ABLE TO- I MEAN
WHAT'S HAPPENING TODAY. SO THERE
IS A STANDARDS BODY- WHICH I'M A
SERVICE ADVISER TO CALL THE FIDO
ALLIANCE FIGHTER STANDS FOR FAST
IDENTITY ONLINE. MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED COMPANIES FROM ACROSS
THE GLOBE IN SECURITY BANKING
PAYMENTS HEALTHCARE BY THE
GOVERNMENTS THERE AS WELL ALL
WORKING AND HOW CAN YOU ACTUALLY
IN BAD. PASSWORD LIST
AUTHENTICATION. AND YOUR DEVICE
AS OPPOSED TO HAVE TO BE SOME.
THAT'S GONNA BE BOLTED ON AND SO
YOU KNOW WHAT THE FUTURE LOOKS
LIKE. IS INSTEAD OF A PASSWORD
WHICH IS A KNOWLEDGE BASE
FACTOR. AND THEN SOMETHING ELSE.
IT'S YOU KNOW THE FIRST FACTOR
CAN BE UNLOCKED MY PHONE. BACK
IN BIOMETRIC ONLY ON THIS DEVICE
YOUKNOW. AND THEN THAT'S IT
UNLOCKS A CRYPTOGRAPHIC KEY PAIR
THAT CAN BE USED BEHIND THE
SCENES TO LOG ME IN IN A WAY.
THAT'S FRANKLY MUCH MORE SECURE
THAN. YOU KNOW THAT EVEN WHEN
TALKING ABOUT SOME OF THE ONE
TIME PASSCODES THAT ARE GETTING
FISH THESE DAYS. THOSE ATTACKS
ARE GETTING AUTOMATED LIKE I
MENTIONED BEFORE BY BOTS. YOU'RE
THE FIRST GENERATION MFA WE HAD
IS NOT FISHABLE- BUT THE NEW
FIGHTER STANDARDS ARE NOT IN SO
YOU'RE STARTING TO SEE. THE
WHITE HOUSE JUST. ABOUT THREE
WEEKS AGO. FINALIZED IN TO-
STRATEGY DOCUMENT FOR THE
GOVERNMENT SAYING YOU'RE GONNA
USE PHISHING RESISTANT
AUTHENTICATION ONLY FOR MSA.
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO USE THE
LEGACY STUFF ANYMORE. AND
POINTING TO THE FACT THAT THE
STANDARDS LIKE IF I DON'T HAVE
BEEN BUILT INTO A LOT OF DEVICES
BY. ACTUALLY EVERY YOU KNOW
HARDWARE AND SOFTWARE
MANUFACTURER I THINK THAT'S
WHAT'S GOING TO REALLY START TO
CHANGE THINGS GOING FORWARD.
NAME ADDRESS. MY LAST QUESTION-
YOU KNOW GET I THINK THIS IS IN
YOUR BLUEPRINT- ACTUALLY MISTER
GRANT- BUT- I RECALL. SOMEWHERE
IN IN ONE OF THE TESTS MEASURE
THE BLUEPRINT IT WAS STATED
THAT. THE SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER
IS BAKED INTO OUR CODES THAT WE
WOULD HAVE TO ACTUALLY GO IN AND
REMOVE SUCH. RELIANCE ON SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBER. TO BE ABLE TO
MOVE TO ALTERNATIVES. SUCH AS
THE MOBILE DRIVER'S LICENSE YOU
PROPOSE- IS ANYONE HAVE YOU DONE
ELSE'S OF WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE AT
THE STATE LEVEL IF WE WERE TO
TRY TO. DO WHAT YOU'RE TALING
ABOUT. WHERE IN THE STATE CODE
WOULD WE POTENTIALLY NEED TO
REMOVE- REFERENCES AND RELIANCE
ON SUCH SCARY NUMBERS OR IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT YOU COULD LOOK
INTO FOR US. I HAVE TO LOOK INTO
IT AND I DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
KNOWLEDGE OF CALIFORNIA'S YOU
KNOW LAWS AND REGULATIONS- ON
THE TOPICS IT TO KNOW- BUT- THIS
IS ONE OF THE POINTS THAT WE
MADE. IN OUR POLICY BLUEPRINT
WHICH WAS IT WAS INTERESTING
WHEN WE WERE. WRITING THIS
BLUEPRINT IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
OUR CONFERENCE ROOM. WITH YOU
KNOW OUR MEMBERS AND I ASK
COMPANIES WHY IS. TIME I SEE A
BREACH HAPPENS SSNS ARE LOST
WHAT DO YOU HAVE THESE FOUR IN
THE FIRST PLACE. AND THE ANSWER
WAS. WELL A LOT OF TIMES WE HAVE
THEM BECAUSE THE GOVERNMENT TOLD
US WE HAD TO. YOUR PARTICULAR IN
FINANCIAL SERVICES BUT WE
ACTUALLY DID SOME ANALYSIS AT
LEAST LOOKING AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL. I THINK WE FOUND NINETEEN
DIFFERENT LAWS AND REGULATIONS
THAT SAID. YOU KNOW COMPANIES
HAVE TO COLLECT AND RETAIN SSNS
FOR DIFFERENT PURPOSES SOME OF
THEM MADE A LOT OF SENSE. OTHERS
I THINK THERE WAS ONE. THE COAST
GUARD SAYS IF YOU'RE REGISTERING
A BOAT OVER. FORTY YOU'RE
DONATING BLOOD YOU HAVE TO GIVE
AN ACCESS AND PROBABLY BECAUSE
THEY WANT TO TRACK YOU DOWN IF
THERE'S A PROBLEM- SO I DO THINK
IT COULD BE WORSE- WE'VE NEVER
DONE AN ANALYSIS IN CALIFORNIA
THAT WOULD PROBABLY TAKE SOME
WORK. BUT IT WOULD BE GREAT TO
UNDERSTAND WHERE THERE ARE
REQUIREMENTS IN CALIFORNIA.
BETTER REQUIRING THE ASSISTANCE
YOU MAY BE OVER USED IN PLACES
WHERE IT DOESN'T NEED TO BE.
THANK YOU MR GRANT- THANK YOU
PANELISTS- SENATOR ALAN YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS. NO I'M I'M AS I
SAID THE NUMBER OF YOU HAVE ANY
- THANK YOU SO MUCH AND YOU GUYS
HAVE ANY CLOSING REMARKS THAT
YOU LIKE TO MAKE. THE STOCK.
THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN SENATOR
MEN. FOR CHAIRING THIS COMMITTEE
BRINGS TOGETHER AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO FUTURE HEARINGS.
THANK YOU SENATOR THANK YOU
PALACE AND I GUESS I JUST I WAS
I WAS VERY STRUCK BY THIS
HEARING I THINK WE ALL LEARNED A
LOT I APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT I THINK WE ARE
VERY INTERESTED IN THIS STATE
CALIFORNIA AS AS WAS NOTED
EARLIER I LIKE TO THINK OF
OURSELVES AS A NATIONAL LEADER
IN AND CLEARLY WE'RE FACING A
MASSIVE PROBLEM HERE IN THIS
COUNTRY- AND I THINK. WHILE WE
WAIT FOR THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
TO IMPLEMENT SOME OF THE CHANGES
THAT YOU THAT YOU PROPOSED- WE
THINK THAT WE HERE IN THE STATE
CAN START MOVING MORE NIMBLY- IN
ADOPTING SOME OF THE SUGGESTIONS
WERE MADE TODAY AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO ENGAGE
WITH YOU ALL- SO WITH THAT-
BEFORE. I WOULD LIKE TO INVITE
THE PUBLIC WANTING TO
PARTICIPATE TO CALL IN NOW
AGAIN- PLEASE DIAL THIS TOLL
FREE NUMBER EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO
NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR. AND
WHEN PROMPTED PLEASE USE THE
ACCESS CODE SEVEN SIX NINE SEVEN
ONE EIGHT EIGHT WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO ANYONE WANTING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT- DUE TO
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE LENGTH
OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS IN CLEANING
PROTOCOLS. QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS WILL BE LIMITED TO ONE
MINUTE EACH HOW DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO
OH THREE. NO WE DO NOT. THANK
YOU WILL MOVE ON TO THE
WITNESSES WAITING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT VIA
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS MODERATOR
IF- YOU PLEASE PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT WE CAN BEGIN. TO
LISTEN JOHN IF YOU LIKE TO
PROVIDE- PUBLIC COMMENT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU LIKE TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AND
MODERATOR CAN GIVE YOU THE TOTAL
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WAITING TEST
FOR. AT THIS TIME THERE'S NO
WINNING QUEUE. AND TESTING I
THINK WE'LL WAIT JUST A MINUTE
OR SO THEN AND- IF THERE ARE NO
MORE CALLING. WE WILL CONCLUDE.
HERE ARE A MODERATOR DO WE HAVE
ANYONE ON THE LINE AT THIS POINT
. THERE'S STILL NO ONE IN Q.
OKAY WELL THEN THANK YOU I WANT
TO THANK OUR PANELISTS FOR
JOINING US TODAY AND PROVIDING
SUCH IMPORTANT TESTIMONIES. I
WAS ON I THINK MY COLLEAGUES
NUMBER THIS COMMITTEE THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE FOR
JOINING US TODAY- AND IF YOU'RE
NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE SURFING SERVICE-
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO SUBMIT YOUR
SUGGESTIONS OR COMMENTS IN
WRITING. TO THE SENATE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON CYBER SECURITY AND
IDENTITY THEFT PREVENTION OR
VISIT OUR WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS
AND SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO
US AND WE WANT INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORD. THANK YOU AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION.
THANK YOU AGAIN TO EVERYONE FOR
YOUR PATIENCE AND COOPERATION
WE'VE CONCLUDED THE AGENDA. AND
THE SENATE SELECT COMMITTEE ON.
IDENTITY THEFT PREVENTION IS NOW
ADJOURNED. THANK YOU FOR YOUR.